stehen der erste Redner zu diesem
Einzelplan kommt von der Opposition Ingo
gedechens ist das Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss
also die SPD ist für 20 FDP ist für
abseits wir werden sehen wir es dabei
rauskommt
nach dem Start der Ampel hatte ich für
kurze Zeit die Hoffnung dass dieser
Zauber zu spürbaren Verbesserung bei der
Bundeswehr führen könnte gerade nach der
Rede des Bundeskanzlers Ende Februar war
meine Fraktion und ich positiv
überrascht endlich schien die SPD
erkannt zu haben dass die jahrelange
Blockade einer vernünftigen Ausstattung
der Bundeswehr in den Jahren der großen
Koalition falsch war endlich schien die
SPD er kann zu haben wie dieser strös
die Finanzplanung des damaligen
Finanzministers Olaf Scholz für die
Bundeswehr war und heute leider immer
noch ist der
Verteidigungshaushalt den wir heute
beraten zeigt dass dieser Zauber schnell
verflogen ist und dabei hatten nicht
wenige gerade in den Reihen der genossen
in den Reihen der genossen die Hoffnung
dass die Frau Ministerin die Mutter der
Kompanie hätte werden können
mittlerweile erkennen die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten dass sie die böse
Stiefmutter der Bundeswehr ist ohne
Verständnis für die wirklichen
Notwendigkeiten aber ausgestattet mit
einer diffusen Auffassung für eine
effektive Sicherheitspolitik die gerade
in dieser Zeit von elementarer Bedeutung
werden
Reden und Handeln dieser Bundesregierung
fallen eklatant auseinander kurz um
dieser Haushalt ist für die Bundeswehr
ein Desaster schauen wir in das
Zahlenwerk um einige Beispiele zu nennen
in der aktuellen angespannten Situation
ist es der ernsthafte Vorschlag der
Ampel den Einzelplan umfasst 400
Millionen im Vergleich zu diesem Jahr
abzusenken und das versuchen sicherlich
die Redner der Ampelkoalition gleich
noch als Erfolg zu verkaufen das liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist einfach nur
absurd in den Haushaltsberatung war für
viele Bereiche noch finanzieller
Spielraum für Arbeit und Soziales gab es
2,9 Milliarden mehr für Gesundheit 2,4
Milliarden für Bauen und Wohnen 2,3
Milliarden nur
nur der Verteidigungshaushalt ging leer
aus okay nicht ganz sage und schreibe
gibt es 13 Millionen Euro mehr und
denken Sie jetzt nicht meine Damen und
Herren dass damit ein sinnvolles Projekt
zusätzlich auf den Weg gebracht werden
soll nein es ist nur eine
wechselkursanpassung weil der Dollar am
Stärke gewonnen hat Fazit alle bekommen
mehr Geld nur die Bundeswehr geht trotz
gestiegener Betriebskosten trotz
galoppierende Inflation leer aus und das
ist das Unfassbare ampelergebnis dieser
Bereinigungssitzung 18,5 Stunden dieser
Haushaltsberatung
als Union haben wir ein soliden
Gegenvorschlag gemacht unter Einhaltung
der Schuldenbremse haben wir beantragt
das zu machen was sie Frau Ministerin
angekündigt haben nämlich endlich
ausreichend Geld für unsere Soldaten und
Soldaten zur Verfügung zu stellen um das
nato-2 Prozent Ziel schon im nächsten
Jahr zu erreichen und das wäre auch
dringend nötig mit ihrem Haushalt fehlt
es an allen Ecken und Enden am Geld nur
mit den verrücktesten haushaltstricks
kriegt das Ministerium noch die
finanziellen Enden zusammen aber jeder
weiß dass wir genau jetzt jetzt größere
Rüstungsvorhaben die weitere Corvetten
Fregatten Schützenpanzer anstoßen
müssten weil dieses Gerät sowieso erst
in einigen Jahren zur Verfügung stehen
könnte mit unseren Vorschlägen wäre das
möglich gewesen das hat die Ampel aber
trotz besseren Wissens abgelehnt
meine Damen und Herren wir erwarten
immer noch auf ein belastbaren
Wirtschaftsplan für das Sondervermögen
dabei schmilzt es wie Butter in der
Sonne darüber hinaus ersetzt es leider
kein soliden Finanzplan im originären
Verteidigungsetat aber mit dem
versprochenen aufwuchs konnten sie Frau
Ministerin sich weder beim Bundeskanzler
weder beim Bundesfinanzminister und
schon gar nicht im Kabinett durchsetzen
natürlich verstehe ich dass man bei
diesen handfesten und ehrlichen
Argumenten einen Oppositionspolitiker
ungern zuhört aber wenn sie schon nicht
auf mich hören wollen Frau Lambrecht
hören Sie doch bitte auf die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aus der eigenen Ampel
Koalition selbst die werbeauftragte
kritisiert die ich vorhin nicht begrüßt
habe die Kollegen Nanni von den Grünen
kommt zu dem Schluss schnelle
Entscheidung zur Beschaffung hätte es
schon vor dem Sommer Gebrauch und zwar
durch die Ministerin so Frau Nanni
Kollegin Carsten klein der ja auch
gleich noch reden wird von der FDP sagt
ich verstehe nicht warum wir so lange
brauchen um Bestellung auf den Weg zu
bringen und auch unser geschätzter
Hauptbericht erstatte Andreas Schwarz
verliert die Geduld und warnt das Geld
aus dem Sondervermögen muss schneller
abfließen sonst erreichen wir das 2%
Ziel nicht hören Sie doch Frau
Ministerin zumindestens auf die eigenen
Leute die ihre Arbeit ein derart
schlechtes Zeugnis ausstellen und das im
Haushaltsausschuss das erste Mal seit
Menschen gedenken die Regierungsfraktion
Anträge der eigenen Bundesregierung
ablehnt sollte Ihnen auch ein letzter
Warnschuss sein ich hoffe liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass wir für
diesen Warnschuss überhaupt noch die
Munition haben
zum Abschluss noch ein Wort zu ihrer
neuen Kommunikationsstrategie Frau
Ministerin sie könnten sich ehrlich
machen und sagen ich kann mich im
Kabinett nicht durchsetzen und dessen
wegen müssen sicher geglaubte
Rüstungsprojekte gestrichen werden
unredlich wird es allerdings dann wenn
sie behaupten alle Streichungen basieren
auf militärischen Rat
wenn sich gegen eine solche Äußerung die
Inspekteure unserer Streitkräfte wären
weil sie um ihre eigene glaubhaft
gegenüber den Soldaten und Soldaten
kennen wenn die sagen das ist nicht
passiert auf militärischen Rat sondern
ist die Entscheidung der Ministerin dann
kriegen die zack ein Maulkorb umgehängt
damit die Wahrheit das Licht der Welt
nicht erblickt aber das hat im BMVg noch
nie funktioniert dass die Wahrheit das
Licht der Welt nicht erblickt hat und es
wird auch in Zukunft nicht funktionieren
meine Damen und Herren ich erwarte von
einer Inhaberin der befehls- und
Kommando Gewalt dass sie für den
Einzelplan kämpft dass sie für eine
vernünftige Ausstattung der Bundeswehr
kämpft und dass sie für unsere Soldaten
und Soldaten einsteht und das erkenne
ich bei dieser Ministerin nicht
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege seelekens und
geh dich ins hart hier auch die
werbeauftragte des Deutschen Bundestags
Eva Högl erwähnt sie ist ja praktisch
die Anwältin der Soldaten und Soldaten
und wohnt deswegen natürlich dieser
Debatte bei
Liebe Ministerin liebe werbeauftragte
meine geschützten Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Ingo du hast ganz schön schwarz gesehen
und das im wahrsten Sinne der Wald des
Wortes auch der Partei der du angehörst
verschwende nie eine Krise denn sie gibt
uns die Gelegenheit große Dinge zu tun
dieses Zitat von Rahmen Immanuel dem
ehemaligen Bürgermeister von Chicago und
heutigen Botschafter in Japan Druck
genau das aus was wir mit diesem
Haushalt wirklich getan haben große
Dinge dieser Haushalt dieser
Verteidigungshaushalt steht für
Fortschritt und für Aufbruch unserem
Kanzler Olaf Scholz und der
Verteidigungsministerin gebührt daher
unser Dank für mutige Entscheidungen im
Verteidigungsbereich liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir haben eine unsichere
Zeit die sind Entwicklung ungewiss
Inflation gerade hoch Lieferketten
brüchig Beschaffungsprozesse sind
schwierig und komplex und das alles
macht einen Verteidigungshaushalt am
Ende des Tages zu schaffen
50,1 Milliarden im Einzelplan und 8,5
Milliarden Euro aus dem Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr als insgesamt über 58
Milliarden Euro haben wir
2023 für die Bundeswehr zur Verfügung
gestellt und das lieber Ingo ist ein
Rekordwert so eine sumatsende Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland noch nie
gegeben viel Geld das sind richtige und
wichtige Projekte investiert wird hierzu
gehören dringend benötigte
ausrüstungsvorhaben wie den schweren
Transporthubschrauber der jahrelang in
der Entscheidung vor sich hergeschoben
wurde die F35 beispielsweise die jetzt
entschieden ist es gehört aber auch dazu
weitere persönliche Schutzausrüstung für
Soldatinnen und Soldaten
Nachtsichtgeräte und vieles mehr in den
knappen Jahr ist viel passiert aber
nicht nur die Beschaffung neuer
Waffensysteme wird investiert
Schwerpunkte sind auch Investitionen
Digitalisierung in wehrtechnische
Forschung natürlich auch in die
materiale Haltung in Personal und in den
Ausbau der Infrastruktur meine Damen und
Herren neue Waffensysteme führen aber
auch zu deutlich höheren Betriebskosten
auf die dieser Verteidigungshaushalt
reagiert und zukünftige
Verteidigungshaushalte auch weiter
reagieren müssen Sicherheit meine Damen
und Herren gibt es einfach nicht zum
Nulltarif bereits 2023 bedrohende
Betriebsausgaben mit über 28,5
Milliarden Euro weit mehr als die Hälfte
der Ausgaben im Einzelplan 14 und die
Tendenz ist leider steigend zudem muss
der Verteidigungshaushalt auch die
Kosten auffangen und berücksichtigen die
aufgrund der derzeitigen massiven
Preiserhöhungen langfristig nur schwer
kalkulierbar sind fakt ist große Dinge
erfordern große Taten und richtiges
Handeln und mutige Entscheidungen der
Einzelplan und das Sondervermögen sind
deshalb die richtige Antwort um die
großen Lücken der letzten Jahre
bestmöglich zu schließen
aber machen wir uns nichts vor
irgendwann ist auch der 100
milliarden-topf leer deshalb da muss
unser Blick auf den
Verteidigungshaushalt weiterhin
gerichtet bleiben der ohne eine
entsprechende Steigung das könnte
nämlich auch zur Wahrheit dazu in den
nächsten Jahren nur schwer funktionieren
wird denn wir sind uns alle einig wir
wollen und brauchen eine leistungsfähige
Bundeswehr die zeitnah die Ausrüstung
erhält die sie braucht um der Landwirt
und bündnisverteidigung gerecht zu
werden wir waren sind und bleiben ein
zuverlässiger Bündnispartner in der
Sicherheitsarchitektur der westlichen
demokratischen Welt Deutschland ist sich
auch seiner neuen Verantwortung in
dieser Welt bewusst und dafür auch noch
mal mein Dank an alles Soldaten und
Soldaten die hier für einstehen
die Koalition hat in der sogenannten
Bereinigungssitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses noch Veränderungen
im Verteidigungshaushalt vornehmen
können die zu mehr transparenzklarheit
und Effizienz beigetragen haben wir
haben eine Parlamentsarmee und diese
Aufgabe nehmen wir als Parlamentarier
auch ernst erwähnen möchte ich dass wir
die Anfangsfinanzierung für die
elektronische Gesundheitsakte auf den
Weg gebracht haben sie soll endlich die
bisher in Papierform vorliegende
Gesundheitsakte der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten ersetzen ferner haben wir den
munitionstitel nochmal zum eine
Milliarde erhöht und ganz wichtig meine
Damen und Herren wir haben das
sogenannte kommandeursgeld noch mal
erhöht und haben sie im Jahre
20223 verdoppelt damit sind vor Ort
genügend finanzielle Mittel vorhanden um
kurzfristige Beschaffungen
unbürokratisch vornehmen zu können und
als letztes meine Damen und Herren und
das war auch ein besonderes Anliegen wir
fordern dass bei Beschaffungsvorhaben
zum schweren Transporthubschrauber zu
F35 zum sea Fan Aufklärer P8 das
Wesentliche Wertschöpfungsanteile bei
wartungsinstandsetzungs- und
Inspektionsarbeiten in Deutschland
verbleiben damit werden wir auch unsere
industriepolitischen Verantwortung
gerecht meine Damen und Herren lassen
nämlich zum Schluss noch einen kurzen
Blick auf künftige Vorhaben setzen bei
vielen Infrastruktur und Baumaßnahmen
muss der Fokus zukünftig auf mehr
Nachhaltigkeit gesetzt werden das Thema
erneuerbare Energien muss auch bei der
Bundeswehr übrigens auch bei anderen
bundesligenschaften ganz oben gelistet
werden das gilt für den Bau von
Photovoltaikanlagen für
Energieerzeugungsanlagen Wärmepumpen bei
Immobilien für entsprechende
Speichereinheiten aber auch für
Fahrzeuge mit Elektro und
Wasserstoffantrieb und den Einsatz
synthetischer Kraftstoffe hergestellt
aus grünem Strom und da gibt's schon
einige gute Beispiele beispielsweise die
stauferkaserne in Pfullendorf die mit
Geothermie arbeitet meine Damen und
Herren Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende
ist das Motto dieses
Verteidigungshaushalts und ich bin
überzeugt wir haben für unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten gute und
notwendige Dinge getan ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei allen Beteiligten für
die konstruktive und vertrauensvolle
Zusammenarbeit in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten das war sicherlich viel Arbeit
manchmal auch anstrengend hat viel Zeit
gekostet aber gute Zeit im Industrie
investiert haben um am Ende auch ein
gutes Ergebnis unseren Soldatinnen und
Soldaten vorliegen zu können in diesem
Sinne herzlichen Dank für Aufmerksamkeit
einen schönen guten Nachmittag liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und liebe
Besucherinnen und Besucher auf den
Tribünen der diesen Zusammenhang begrüße
ich auch die werbeauftragte des
Deutschen Bundestages Eva Högl
die Platz genommen hat sozusagen auf der
beziehungsweise hinter der Länderbank
also
spiegelbildlich zur Regierungsbank zur
bundesregierungsbank gibt es ja die
Länderbank die Ländervertreter
allerdings sehr selten hier im Bundestag
aber da ist ein extra reserviert für die
werbeauftragte des Bundestages eben Eva
Hügel so nächster Redner jetzt Michael
Essen für die AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im Saal
und bei Youtube 50,1 Milliarden Euro
groß wird der reguläre Etat des
Verteidigungsministeriums im Jahr 2023
sein weitere 8,5 Milliarden Euro kommen
aus dem sogenannten Sondervermögen das
ist schon eine stolze Summe und
Deutschland nähert sich damit dem 2%
Ziel der NATO ordentlich an die Union
allerdings die das Thema jahrzehntelang
hat schleifen lassen will jetzt
plötzlich auf Biegen und Brechen dass
zwei Prozent Ziel peinlich genau
einhalten ich kann ja verstehen dass es
eine gut klingende Forderung ist das
kann man wunderbar vor sich her tragen
aber ist das überhaupt klug und in der
aktuellen Situation angemessen seit dem
Krieg in der Ukraine hat nicht nur die
allgemeine Inflation zugenommen sondern
im besonderen Maße auch die Inflation
bei Rüstungsgütern es gibt eine
erheblich gestiegene Nachfrage die zu
steigenden Preisen geführt hat und das
bei beschränkten Produktionskapazitäten
die man nicht mal eben so erweitern kann
dazu kommen immer noch andauernden
lieferkettenprobleme und Rohstoff
einfach gesagt wir bekommen für unser
Geld weniger und das ist schlecht denn
wir brauchen von allem viel
obendrein veranstaltet die
internationale Rüstungsindustrie gerade
ein großer Ausverkauf und will auch noch
alte Ladenhüter loswerden das bedeutet
aber nicht dass diese Ware von
Grabbeltisch auch das richtige für
unsere Bundeswehr ist in diesem
Marktumfeld sklavisch an der jährlichen
veranschlage von zwei Prozent
festzuhalten würde zu Ineffizienzen und
Verschwendungen führen das wäre sogar
kontraproduktiv wenn man will dass die
Bundeswehr richtig ausgestattet wird
abgesehen davon hat mir noch keiner von
ihnen überhaupt erklärt wie sie denn das
ganze finanzieren wollen so
Gegenfinanzierung schweigen sie sich
nämlich aus die einzige Fraktion die
darauf eine Antwort hat sind im übrigen
mal wieder wir erzählen Ihnen hier seit
einem dreiviertel Jahr dass sie den
Investitionsbedarf im Einzelplan 14
durch Einsparungen in anderen
Einzelplänen finanzieren müssen und auch
können zum Beispiel aus dem Etat des
Auswärtigen Amtes und des
Bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung aber auch
da geben Sie alle die Euros mit vollen
Händen aus auch die Union kann es da gar
nicht schnell genug machen wenn das Geld
aus Deutschland raus geschafft werden
soll und obendrein stellt die Union dann
beim Verteidigungsetat auch noch
Änderungsanträge die noch nicht mal mehr
populistisch sind ihre Forderungen da
waren ganz und gar realitätsfremd und
jenseits aller haushaltherischer
Vernunft
mit Verlaub Herr Kollege nach der
Lektüre ihrer Anträge hatte ich
kurzzeitig den Eindruck dass die Union
von kriegsflüstern in Warlords
unterwandert wurde die bereits morgen in
die Schlacht ziehen wollen es gibt aber
auch neben der Union noch die Ampel
wollen wir natürlich auch noch erwähnen
dass diese Regierung in der jetzigen
Situation weiterhin auf Eskalation statt
auf Verhandlung setzt ist und bleibt
sicherheitspolitisch auch weiter alles
andere als klug das haben wir in ihr
letztes mal schon erklärt den
Haushaltsberatung ist aber auch
besonders klar zu Tage getreten ihre
Haltung ist nicht nur unvernünftig
sondern sie ist auch verdammt teuer das
schlägt sich in allen Einzelplänen
nieder und lässt sich mit einem Zitat
des englischen Dichters Alexander Probe
zusammenfassen der teuerste Frieden ist
billiger als der billigste Krieg schon
allein aus diesem Gründen sollten Sie
endlich Verhandlungen aufnehmen
aber uns treibt noch eine andere Sorge
um das Vorhaben die Bundeswehr endlich
vernünftig auszustatten ist sehr richtig
und wird von uns auch unterstützt
natürlich bedarf es noch immer einer
grundlegenden Reform der Truppe und da
werden wir auch weiterhin Forderungen
aufstellen doch auch wenn uns in der
Zielvorstellung noch so manches
trennmark muss man sagen dass diese
Regierung auf einem gar nicht so
schlechten Weg ist oder soll ich besser
sagen Ware denn anstatt sich zu 100
Prozent auf das Fähigkeitsprofil der
Bundeswehr konzentriert zu konzentrieren
müssen sich in den letzten Wochen auch
ganz andere Töne in die Debatte ein von
energetischer Sanierung ist die Rede von
Nachhaltigkeit und es soll geprüft
werden und ich zitiere ob im Flugbetrieb
die Verwendung von nicht fossilen
Energiequellen eingesetzt werden kann
denn das Ziel sollte die Verwendung von
bis zu 100% nicht fossilen
flugkraftstoffen sein bitte was
öko-kampfjets ist das jetzt ihr ernst
ich sage es mal ganz direkt angenommen
der Russe Stände tatsächlich vor Berlin
dann wird es mit Sicherheit unseren
letzte Sorge sein um auf den Dächern der
deutschen Kaserne ordentliche
Solaranlagen angebracht sind und ob
unsere nicht vorhandenen Flugzeuge alle
auf Öko umgestellt sind
nicht grüner Schwachsinn ist im Ernst
der Lage nicht angemessen und ich hoffe
dass die Regierung wenigstens bei diesem
hochsensiblen Thema Verteidigung
einigermaßen bei Verstand bleibt sonst
werden wir hier demnächst nämlich
militärfahrräder und keine Panzer
bestellen
wir jedenfalls haben klargemacht was wir
wollen auch liebe FDP schnellere
Verfahren das Auffüllen der
Munitionsvorräte und eine dauerhafte und
nachhaltige Finanzierung der Bundeswehr
nicht ausschulden wenn sie das nicht
hinkriegen Fragen so uns wir wissen wie
das geht danke für die aufmerksam
michael espendilla war das für die
afd-fraktion und nächster jetzt hier im
Rednerpult Sebastian Schäfer ist das für
grünen er ist übrigens der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende des
Gremiums Sondervermögen Bundeswehr dass
ich ja Anfang November konstituiert
hatte besteht aus 13 Abgeordneten und
soll eben die Bewirtschaftung dieses 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr überwachen
meine sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir wissen nicht wann die
schreckliche russische Aggression in der
Ukraine endet in den letzten Wochen und
Tagen zeigte sich nach dem vorrücken an
der ukrainischen Armee wieder welche
Kriegsverbrechen die russische Armee
begangen hat mit welchem Terror Russland
die Ukraine überzieht bei einem kurzen
Besuch in Lewis mit Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus dem Haushaltsausschuss habe
ich selbst einen kurzen Eindruck vom
Leben in der Ukraine bekommen in den
wenigen Stunden in denen wir die Stadt
besucht haben wurde viermal Luftalarm
ausgelöst einen geplantes Gespräch in
einer Berufsschule wurde kurzfristig in
einen Luftschutzkeller verlegt ich habe
die Dunkelheit in der Stadt gesehen
Putins Terror sorgt dafür dass die
Menschen ständig bedroht sind dass
Elektrizität und Heizung aufgrund der
raketenschläge auf die Infrastruktur
ausfallen und doch kann ich nicht
ermessen wie unermesslich das Leid ist
dass die Menschen in der bei ihnen
erfahren
wir müssen weiterhin alles dafür tun
dass die Ukraine ihre Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung verteidigen kann
daher
ist es wichtig dass wir im
Haushaltsverfahren die Mittel für die
ertüchtigungsinitiative wieder deutlich
auf 2,2 Milliarden Euro angehoben haben
damit finanzieren wir ganz wesentlich
die Ausrüstung für die Ukraine der
Verteidigungshaushalt lieber Kollege
gälischens ist eben mehr als der
Einzelplan 14
in dieser Notsituation müssen wir jede
Möglichkeit nutzen und auch Gerät der
Bundeswehr abgeben um zu helfen die
entstehenden Lücken können und werden
wir schließen die Ukraine steht vor
einem harten Winter und benötigt
dringend weitere Unterstützung gerade
für die wichtigen Waffensysteme die wir
geliefert haben wie die Panzerhaubitze
2000 müssen wir die Ersatzteilversorgung
sicherstellen zur Not auch durch
Rückgriff auf die Bestände der
Bundeswehr dann muss so schnell wie
möglich wieder aufgefüllt werden dazu
hat der Haushaltsausschuss eine Maßgabe
beschlossen das gilt insbesondere für
die Munition
die Munitionsversorgung
ist aber nicht nur ein Thema im
Zusammenhang mit der Unterstützung der
ukrainen auch für unsere
Verteidigungsfähigkeit müssen wir da
deutlich zulegen entsprechend haben wir
im parlamentarischen Verfahren Kollege
schwarzharz angesprochen mehr als eine
Milliarde Euro zusätzliche Mittel
bereitgestellt aber das kann nur einen
Anfang sein diesen Kurs werden wir
konsequent fortsetzen und wir müssen
auch mit der Industrie sprechen wie wir
die Kontinuität bei der
Munitionsversorgung sicherstellen können
wir haben bei der Verabschiedung des
Sondervermögens beschlossen dass im DAF
zitieren mehrjährigen Durchschnitt von
maximal fünf Jahren zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts auf Basis der
aktuellen regierungsprognose für
Verteidigungsausgaben nach NATO
Kriterien bereitgestellt werden sollen
auch wenn sie von der Union nun
wiederholt kritisieren dass die Ampel
das Ziel mit diesem Haushalt nicht
erreicht bleibt diese Kritik falsch
unser Ziel
unser Ziel ist und bleibt es die
Bundeswehr angemessen auszurüsten auch
mit dem Blick auf die notwendige
schnelle Lieferung von Material dürfen
wir uns nicht wieder in die Entwicklung
von vielen verschiedenen
Rüstungsprojekten verzetteln die erst
einmal erforscht und erprobt werden
müssen sondern endlich den Mut haben
Markt verfügbare Rüstungsgüter zu
erwerben auch mit dem Blick auf die
Zeitachse dass wir innerhalb von fünf
Jahren das Sondervermögen effektiv
genutzt haben wollen bisher hatte ich
gedacht dass auch die Union dieses Ziel
teilt
umso überraster war ich von Aussagen von
Friedrich Merz in der Welt am Sonntag
vor vergangenen vor vergangene Woche
Herr Merz will offenbar keine
marktverfügbaren Kampfflugzeuge zur
Tornado Nachfolge in den USA kaufen die
sogenannte fünfte Generation die in
vielen NATO-Staaten in den kommenden
Jahren genutzt werden
er setze auf FKS ein luftkampfsystem der
6 Generation das könne beschleunigt
werden sagt der nun bisher war der
Einsatz dieses Systems ab frühestens
2040 geplant und das ist schon sportlich
die Tornados sind ein Auslaufmodell und
wir müssen vertragstreu sein und die
nukleare Teilhabe sichern vielleicht
erklären die geschätzten Kollegen aus
der Unionsfraktion ihren
Fraktionsvorsitzenden einmal dass wir
dringend Markt verfügbare Flugzeuge
anschaffen müssen und dafür nicht auf
ein so umfassendes Entwicklungsprojekt
wie efkasten können
[Applaus]
wir müssen jetzt schnell beschaffen was
bei der Bundeswehr so dringend benötigt
wird herzlichen Dank
Sebastian Schäfer hat es angesprochen in
den Haushaltsberatungen ist deswegen
unter anderem noch mal dazu gekommen ein
zusätzlicher Posten für Munition in Höhe
von etwa 1,1 Milliarden Euro und er hat
auch angesprochen die
Unterstützungsleistung für die Ukraine
die Liste der militärischen
wird von der Bundesregierung wöchentlich
aktualisiert zuletzt ist den Abbau mit
den nato-paten eben zehn Ausgabeposten
noch dazu gekommen darunter eben auch
Munition für die mehrfach Raketenwerfer
gegen den islamischen Staat gekämpft sie
brauchen dringend unsere Unterstützung
es darf nicht mit zweierlei Maß gemessen
werden
die Linke stellt immer drei Fragen an
den Bundeshaushalt ist der Haushalt
sozial ist der Haushalt friedlich ist
der Haushalt ökologisch leider müssen
wir alle diese drei Fragen mit Nein
beantworten jetzt geht es um die Frage
ob diese Haushalt einen Beitrag für
weniger Krieg und mehr Frieden ist
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg erklärt
dass er eine Erhöhung des
verteidigungsetats über das Land
geltende Ziel von zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes hinaus erwartet
das wären 80 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr
als Untergrenze für die Aufrüstung ich
finde das ist eine absurde Forderung
meine Damen und Herren
damit läutet der nato-chef schon die
nächste Runde des wettröstens ein und
Deutschland darf diesen Wahnsinn nicht
länger unterstützen wir brauchen
Abrüstung und Diplomatie statt krieg
meine Damen und Herren
noch nie wurde so viel Geld in der
Bundesrepublik für militärische
Aufrüstung ausgegeben und noch nie war
das Leben in unserem Land so unsicher
wie heute nach NATO Kriterien will die
Regierung im kommenden Jahr 64
Milliarden Euro für das Militär ausgeben
das ist mehr als sie im kommenden Jahr
für Bildung Forschung Familien Senioren
Frauen Jugend Wohnungsbau Umwelt
Naturschutz nukleare Sicherheit
Verbraucherschutz wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit Inneres und Heimat
insgesamt ausgeben wollen ich glaube das
ist der falsche Schwerpunkt meine Damen
und Herren die kleinste Politik wird von
dieser Regierung auf den Krieg und seine
Folgen ausgerichtet selbst einfache
Dinge funktionieren in unserem Land
nicht mehr ein Beispiel hunderte
Medikamente fehlen in den Apotheken
selbst fieberhustensaft ist nicht mehr
zu bekommen sollen die Menschen etwa den
Eindruck bekommen wir leben in einer
Kriegswirtschaft das ist der falsche Weg
meine Damen und Herren
im Jahr 2014 hat die Bundesregierung
32,4 Milliarden Euro für das Militär
ausgegeben 2022 waren es schon 50,4
Milliarden das ist also eine erhebliche
Steigerung die Bundesregierung will die
Rüstungsausgaben auch zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes steigern das
wären dann wie gesagt 80 Milliarden Euro
aber alle betonen hier immer in welch
schlechtem Zustand die Bundeswehr ist
warum stellt eigentlich niemand die
Frage was aus dem ganzen Geld geworden
ist geht es nicht eigentlich dass es
unsere Frage um die Geschäfte der
Rüstungsindustrie werfen wir doch einmal
einen Blick auf die Aktienkurse der
Rüstungskonzerne an dem Tag als der
Koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben wurde
stand im
nein das sind konkrete Zahlen hören sie
gut zu Kollege an dem Tag an dem der
Koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben wurde
stand der Aktienkurs vom Rüstungskonzern
Rheinmetall bei knapp 83 Euro dann wurde
das 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
durchgepeitscht und zwar mit den Stimmen
der Ampel der Union und etlichen Stimmen
der AFD die Aktie schoss auf einen Wert
von über
227 Euro das ist eine Verdreifachung des
Kurses das ist Politik für Vermögen
Aktionäre wir brauchen etwas anderes wir
brauchen eine krisengewinnsteuer für die
Rüstungskonzerne das wäre der richtige
Weg meine Damen und Herren
die Frage ist doch geht es um eine gut
ausgerüstete Armee zur
Landesverteidigung zur
Landesverteidigung dass uns unsere
grundgesetzlich verbriefte Auffassung
oder geht es um die Profite der großen
Waffenschmieden meine Damen und Herren
zu den 64 Milliarden Euro die die
Bundesregierung im nächsten Jahr für
Aufrüstung ausgeben wollen kommen dann
noch einmal 8 Milliarden aus dem
Sondervermögen hinzu wir sind dann schon
bei einem Jahresbudget von 72 Milliarden
Euro zum Vergleich die Krankenhäuser
sollen einen Inflationsausgleich von 6
Milliarden Euro in zwei Jahren bekommen
die bräuchten aber 15 Milliarden Euro um
ihre Kosten zu decken meine Damen und
Herren noch nie in diesem Jahrtausend
standen wir so kurz vor einem
atomarenkrieg und das darf einer
gemeinsamen international Anstrengung um
dieses unbedingt zu verhindern das ist
die Aufgabe herzlichen Dank
für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Carsten klein
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
300 Milliarden Euro
300 Milliarden Euro stellt dieser
Deutsche Bundestag die Steuerzahlerinnen
und Steuerzahler der Bundesregierung dem
Bundesverteidigungsministerium zur
Verfügung für die Ausrüstung und
Ausstattung unserer Bundeswehr für die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten 300 Milliarden
Euro in dieser Legislaturperiode und es
bedeutet für 2023
58,5 Milliarden Euro das sind 8,1
Milliarden Euro mehr
mehr als 2022 und das sind vor allem
über 11 Milliarden Euro mehr als die
letzte unionsgeführte Bundesregierung
für 2023 geplant hatte
25 Prozent zusätzliche Ausgaben für die
Verteidigung dieses Landes und das zeigt
noch mal dass wir als Ampel uns sehr
bewusst sind die Verantwortung
wahrnehmen für die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses Landes
dass wir vor allem aber diese
zeitenwände auch mit Leben füllen und
das obwohl wir große Versäumnisse und
dafür sprechen diese Zahlen auch große
Versäumnisse der Vorgänger der Regierung
der unionsgeführten Regierung übernommen
haben für eins aber liebe Kollegen
können diese Zahlen nicht herhalten
nämlich für die für den Vorwurf den
Holstein Friedrich Merz und als jetzt
auch Kollege sind gesagt hat dass wir
wenige für die Bundeswehr für Ausgaben
würden diese Vorwurf ist einfach nicht
zutreffend und es soll an dieser Stelle
auch noch mal klar festgehalten werden
aus diesem großen Zahlen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Erwachsenen
aber auch große Verantwortung auf der
einen Seite Frau Ministerin die
Verantwortung das aus diesen großen
Mitteln aus dieser
Haushaltsmitteln auch Projekte werden
die bei den Soldatinnen und Soldaten
ankommen auf der anderen Seite aber auch
die Verantwortung dass wir mit
Transparenz und Klarheit gegenüber den
BürgerInnen und der Bürger und auch
gegenüber dem Bundestag gerade mit
Hinblick auf den Sondervermögen
unterwegs sind 100 Milliarden Euro
Neuverschuldung gibt uns auch
Verantwortung für Klarheit und
Transparenz oder der Bundesrechnungshof
berichter noch mal unterstrichen aber
das haben vor allem die Ampelkoalition
Fraktionen FDP SPD und Grüne im
Haushaltsausschuss auch mit einem
Beschluss noch mal hinterlegt die werden
diese Transparenz und Klarheit
herstellen im Gremium des
Sondervermögens mit einem
Quartalsbericht in dem festgehalten wird
wie die Mittel verwendet werden wann die
Mittel Bindung stattfinden wird man die
Mittel für Ausgaben werden wann die
Projekte mit welchen Zwischenschritten
dann realisiert werden und das stellt
die Transparenz und die Klarheit her die
auch ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen 300
Milliarden Euro ermöglicht das erreichen
dass zwei prozentstil auch in dieser
Legislaturperiode wir haben uns ja
gemeinsam vorgenommen in dem Gesetz dass
wir die sind Durchschnitt über fünf
Jahre erreichen wollen aber hinter den
Prozentwert stehen natürlich Projekte
Projekte die die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
unseres Landes erhöhen sollen und dafür
spielt das Sondervermögen eine zentrale
Rolle ist ein zentrales Instrument das
natürlich in den nächsten zehn Jahren
ermöglichen soll langlaufprojekte
Projekte die groß und finanzintensiv
sind durch zu finanzieren das ist kein
statisches Instrument wie man der ein
oder anderen Diskussion in Deutschland
heute entnehmen konnte sondern ist ein
sehr dynamisches Instrument dass diese
Ziele erreichen soll hinter diesen
Mitteln Frau Ministerin steht die
Realisierung von wichtigen Projekten
einige wurden schon angesprochen die
Nachfolge des Tornados nukleare Teilhabe
das Raketenabwehr Schild oder auch die
mittleren Kräfte des Herrn dringend
nötig sind und nicht zuletzt die
persönliche Schutzausrüstung der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten haben wir schon
beschlossen haben die schon unterwegs
ist und die bis 2025 dann auch bei den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sein sondern
auch deshalb trifft die Aussage von
Friedrich Merz nicht zu dass aus dem
Sondervermögen noch kein Projekt
gestartet worden ist nein dieses
Sondervermögen ist schon aktiv und sorgt
schon für Projekte die bald bei den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sein soll
aber Frau Ministerin
richtig ist natürlich auch der Bundestag
hat ihnen enorme Mittel zur Verfügung
gestellt und jetzt kommt es darauf an
dass sie dafür Sorge tragen dass das
Haus dafür Sorge trägt dass diese Mittel
auch bei den Soldatinnen und Soldaten
ankommt und da können wir noch mehr
Fahrt aufnehmen auch mit Blick auf den
Herbst soll noch mal festgehalten sein
dass viel zu wenig 25 Millionen Vorlagen
den Haushaltsausschuss erreicht haben da
können wir noch besser werden da können
wir noch Fahrt aufnehmen oder müssen wir
auch noch Fahrt aufnehmen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Sondervermögen entstehen natürlich jetzt
auch Folgekosten im materiale halt beim
Personal aber natürlich vor allem auch
beim Thema Munition deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir die Mittel noch mal mit
über 1,1 Milliarden Euro erhöht haben in
der bereinigungssitzungen im übrigen
sind das dann 400 wird für Munition 400
Millionen Euro dann haben wir mehr
eingestellt als die Union überhaupt in
2021 überhaupt vorgesehen hatte aber wir
müssen deshalb auch eine Diskussion
darüber führen in Zukunft bei dem 2%
sind nicht nur dass die Haushalt
Teilnehmer aufwachsen sondern auch über
die Verteilung innerhalb vom Haushalt
vor der Wende 1990 war 20 Prozent des
Bundeshaushaltes für
Verteidigungsausgaben selbst in das zehn
Prozent des zeigt über diese Diskussion
diese Diskussion über die Verteilung
müssen wir führen denn Frieden und
Freiheit werden durch die Bundeswehr und
die Sicherheitskräfte verteidigt und
diese Verteidigungsfähigkeit ist
Voraussetzung dafür dass wir über alle
anderen politischen Themen auch
weiterhin souverän entscheiden können
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit das
zieht sich durch diesen haushaltstag
durch das unterschiedlich gerechnet wird
zwischen ampelregierung und zum Beispiel
Opposition Friedrich Merz hat heute
morgen Olaf Scholz vorgeworfen im
Zusammenhang mit dem Sondervermögen der
Bundeswehr einen Bruch seines
versprechen es war nicht viel verabredet
mindestens zwei Prozent für Verteidigung
ausgegeben werden
hat am 1 Juni hier im Deutschen
Bundestag gesagt ich zitiere Schluss mit
dem kaputtsparen mit Zögern und Zaudern
vor allen Dingen auch Schluss damit das
wichtige Entscheidungen viel zu lange
verschleppt worden meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ein gutes halbes Jahr
danach müssen wir feststellen das ist
alles nicht gelungen die Ministerin
wirkt im Tagesgeschäft planlos mit
konzeptionellen Aufgaben völlig
überfordert sie spielt in
internationalen und
sicherheitspolitischen Debatten und
Strukturen überhaupt keine Rolle
wir diskutieren den Haushalt der
Verteidigungshaushalt zeigt drei Dinge
erstens ein Bundeskanzler der sein
Versprechen nicht einhalten kann
zweitens einen bündnispolitischen
Offenbarungseid und drittens
katastrophale Aussichten für die
deutsche Bundeswehr
die zeitenwände das große Wort dass der
Bundeskanzler am 27 Februar geführt hat
findet nicht statt Herr Kollege und
seine Ankündigung von jetzt ab Jahr für
Jahr von jetzt ab beginnen in diesem
Jahr mehr als zwei Prozent für
Verteidigung auszugeben ist es
bestenfalls eine vollmundige
Sonntagsrede geblieben oder eine
grandiose Täuschung der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten unserer Bundeswehr und unserer
Verbündeten und Partner
das schockierende
daran ist dass die Bundesregierung noch
nicht einmal den Versuch macht dieses
skandalöse Verhalten auch nur annähernd
zu kaschieren aber damit setzt der
ehemalige Finanzminister Scholz und die
SPD ihre Politik der Missachtung
gegenüber bündniszusagen und Bedarfen
der Bundeswehr fort wie wir es ja schon
in den vergangenen zwei Wahlperioden
gelernt haben es war die Union die immer
wieder seit 2014 verlangt haben dass wir
ein Haushalt Vorliegen der die zwei
Prozent Erfordernisse erfüllt und es war
immer wieder die sozialdemokratische
Fraktion die dieses verhindert hat auch
wenn sie jetzt in den netten Dienst tun
das nicht zuzugeben das ist die Wahrheit
das wissen wir alles ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender hat im Sommer 2019
freimütig erklärt ich fühle mich an die
zwei Prozent nicht gebunden
so viel zu ihrem Ohr und er hat dann die
F35 die ja hier Herr Kollege Dr schwarz
erwähnt worden sind und die F18 als
US-amerikanische Atombomber verunglimpft
und noch am 26 Februar diesen Jahres am
26 februar einen Tag vor der Rede des
Bundeskanzlers wird er zitiert mit der
Aussage immer noch mehr Aufrüstung kann
nicht die Antwort sein das Ergebnis ist
die Sozialdemokratie hier im Deutschen
Bundestag hat ein wie Gottes Verhältnis
zur Bundeswehr wenn man es nicht als
schizophren bezeichnen will wir müssen
immer wieder feststellen am Ende stehen
sie nicht hinter der Bundeswehr
[Applaus]
wir müssen darüber reden meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie endlich
umgesetzt wird was in der
konzeptionellen Planung für die deutsche
Bundeswehr notwendig ist und das
natürlich das allererste das Thema der
Beschaffung die Soldaten und Soldaten
Herr Kollege klein im Gegensatz zu ihren
Ausführungen müssen feststellen unter
Führung von Verteidigungsministerin
Lambrecht wird die Bundeswehr jeden Tag
schwächer es kommt nichts an
kein einziges bestellungsvorhaben wird
realisiert überhaupt nichts wird
ausgeliefert hinzu kommt die Bundeswehr
hat jetzt mittlerweile einen
katastrophalen munitionsbestand die
artillerietruppe ist im Grunde ohne
Munition kann überhaupt nicht mehr den
scharfen Schuss üben und dafür tragen
sie die politische Verantwortung das
Geld haben wir zur Verfügung gestellt
Beschaffungen sind von ihnen nicht
ermöglicht worden
was die Konzeption der Bundeswehr
ansteht erwarte ich von der
bundesverteidigungsministerin dass sie
mal klar liegt welche Bundeswehr der
Zukunft will sie denn wir haben immer
noch die Struktur einer Afghanistan
Armee einer einer Armee die darauf
ausgerüstet ist insbesondere Einsätze im
Ausland zu realisieren mittlerweile ist
ein klar Landes- und bündnisverteidigung
muss Priorität sein dafür gibt es
Papiere der Bundes die von der
Bundeswehr erarbeitet worden sind aber
weil die ideologische Verblendung so
groß ist es ist eben noch in der letzten
Legislaturperiode erarbeitet worden sind
die Papiere sofort in die Schublade
gelegt worden einzelne Teile sind wieder
herausgeholt worden einzelne Sachen
davon werden umgesetzt aber eine
Umstrukturierung der Bundeswehr die
führungsfähig ist die wirklich Bündnis
und Landesverteidigung leisten kann
findet nicht statt und deswegen sage ich
konzeptionell ist diese
Verteidigungsministerin völlig
überfordert und liefert nicht das ab was
die Soldaten und Soldaten schon in
dieser Zeit verdient hätten und was
dringend notwendig gewesen wäre und ich
komme zum internationalen Bereich und
sehe mal davon ab dass die
Verteidigungsministerin im Gegensatz zu
vielen Vorgängern übrigens auch der
soziald aus der Sozialdemokratie ich
erinnere an die verteilungsminister
Frank Georg Leber bis zu Peter Struck
Handy die wirklich
ein großen Einsatz geleistet haben hohe
Anerkennung hatten das wäre ja das wäre
mal ein Vorbild gewesen an keiner
internationalen Debatte nimmt diese
Verteidigungsministerin an keiner
sicherheitspolitischen Debatte mehr Teil
es finden Konferenzen über Konferenzen
statt Mannheimer Dialog Halifax Security
conference es sind verteilungsminister
und Verteidigungsminister aus ganz
Europa aus der ganzen Welt der NATO da
wer nie da es ist Christine lumprecht
und dann ist es kein Wunder dass
natürlich die ganze Ideenwelt mit der
jetzt an dem minus mal Einsatz herangeht
völlig ungeordnet ist im Frühsommer
fabuliert sie darüber wir ziehen im
Sommer ab wenn die Hubschrauber nicht
entsprechend so ergänzt werden wie
Deutschland sie hatte was stellen wir
fest gibt es eine entsprechenden
Hubschraubereinsatz wie wir ihn hatten
nein trotzdem bleiben wir da jetzt gibt
es ein verlängerungsmandat für
anderthalb Jahre wo die Soldaten
Soldaten den Auftrag den sie eigentlich
bekommen sollen überhaupt gar nicht
vollständig erfüllen können was sollen
die Soldaten und Soldaten dann noch da
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
dann ziehen Sie sie gleich ab dann
ziehen Sie sich gleich ab als
Feigenblatt taugen unsere Soldaten und
Soldaten nicht und deswegen muss ich
nach einem Jahr etwa einem Jahr des
Dienstes sagen Frau Ministerin sie haben
gesagt wenn es einfach wäre könnten es
andere machen ich glaube es ist wirklich
besser es würden andere machen danke
schön
der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion Johann wadepool war das
hat sich nicht nur am Wehretat
abgearbeitet sondern vor allem auch an
der Ministerin die Ministerin wirke im
Tagesgeschäft planlose Spiele in
internationalen Debatten überhaupt keine
Rolle dass ein Vorwurf zu Beginn und die
Ministerin hat jetzt Gelegenheit zu
erwidern oder zu ihrem Haushalt zu
sprechen oder beides
liebe Kolleginnen meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren Werte werbeauftragte
nicht alles was lautstark und
breitbeinig vorgetragen wird entspricht
auch der Realität das konnten wir heute
mal wieder erleben was aber der Realität
entspricht ist das diese Bundesregierung
gerade im Bereich der sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik endlich handelt
endlich Entscheidungen trifft und
Schluss ist mit Zaudern mit zögern mit
weggucken mit
ignorieren sowie des unter vielen vielen
Jahren der Vorgänger der Vorgängerinnen
geschehen ist meine Damen und Herren und
ich will das mal durchdeklinieren was
Zeitenwende in praktischer politik
bedeutet der Kollege Kiesewetter hat es
vorhin mal eingefordert ich kann diese
Forderung auch verstehen denn er musste
ja unter den cdu-vorgängerinnen so lange
darauf verzichten dass praktische
Politik umgesetzt wird
deswegen will ich das gerne mal
durchdeklinieren ich möchte das mal
durchdeklinieren in Bezug auf die
ukraine-politik es war diese
Bundesregierung die entschieden hat im
Gegensatz zu vielen anderen dass wir
auch in Länder wie die Ukraine wo ein
kriegt tobt dass wir dahin Waffen
liefern das ist keine einfache
Entscheidung gewesen aber wir haben sie
getroffen und wir haben Sie nicht nur
getroffen sondern wir haben die Waffen
geliefert von mehrfach Raketenwerfern
über Panzerhaubitzen Geparden und
insbesondere das in den letzten Tagen so
wirksame System erysteht das noch nicht
einmal die Bundeswehr zum Einsatz hat
aber uns war es wichtig ganz schnell
gegen diesen Terror aus der Luft von
Raketen und von Drohnen die Ukraine zu
unterstützen und ich kann Ihnen sagen
dass es mehr als wirksame das hat viele
viele Menschen leben gerettet
und wir handeln nicht nur dass wir etwas
liefern sondern wir sorgen auch dafür
dass die entsprechende Ausbildung
gewährleistet ist dass die Munition und
die Ersatzteile gleich mitgeliefert
werden genauso wie es beispielsweise bei
der Panzerhaubitze geschehen ist da war
es uns wichtig dass genau das dann auch
vor Ort geschehen kann und es wird jetzt
weitergehen indem wir ein
instandsetzungszentrum in der Slowakei
noch im Dezember
einrichten so dass an der Grenze sehr
nah ohne lange Wege dann die Waffen die
wir geliefert haben auch instand gesetzt
werden kann das ist zeitenwände in
praktische Politik umgesetzt meine Damen
und Herren
und darüber hinaus darüber hinaus werden
wir uns selbstverständlich und das zur
Frage der spielen keine Rolle
selbstverständlich vielleicht machen
wenn ich immer gleich die großen Worte
und viel Drumherum und viel Pressearbeit
aber wir werden uns ganz beeindruckend
an der ausbildungsmission der
Europäischen Union für die Ukraine
beteiligen denn das ist doch wichtig
damit die Durchhaltefähigkeit auch
gewährleistet ist und es werden wir in
Deutschland in den nächsten Monaten
nämlich bis zum Sommer 23
5000 ukrainische Soldaten ausbilden und
neuen Nationen machen das mit uns
zusammen hier in Deutschland das stärkt
die Durchhaltefähigkeit und das ist ganz
konkrete Politik meine Damen und Herren
zeitenwände ganz konkret umgesetzt
bedeutet auf die Anforderungen der NATO
auch entsprechend vorbereitet zu sein
und zu reagieren das haben wir gemacht
wir sind rahmennationen für Litauen und
deswegen haben wir selbstverständlich
auch dafür gesorgt dass Litauen sich auf
uns als alliierte verlassen kann genauso
wie wir uns auch auf alliierte in
anderen Zeiten verlassen konnten das ist
uns immer wichtig dass wir da
entsprechend auch agieren eben nicht nur
große Versprechungen machen laute Worte
wählen sondern handeln das ist
zeitenwände in ganz konkrete Politik
umgesetzt meine Damen und Herren und was
dazu auch gehört ist dass man nicht nur
den Finger in die Wunde legt wie das in
den Jahren davor gemacht wurde da gibt's
ein Beispiel das spürt das erleben wir
gerade ganz besonders und gerade auch
bedrohlich nämlich dass die Luft
verteidigen und in Europa ganz große
Lücken aufweisen das hat der Kanzler in
seiner Rede in Prag im Sommer noch mal
deutlich gemacht das ist aber nichts
Neues sondern das war sehr sehr lange
bekannt was jetzt aber neu ist dass wir
dagegen handelnde deswegen haben wir
eine Initiative aufgelegt European Sky
Shield damit endlich diese Lücken auch
mal geschlossen werden nicht immer nur
geredet gequatscht wird sondern
gehandelt wird das ist ganz konkrete
Umsetzung von der Zeitenwende und
deswegen werden wir mit diesem Biologie
zusammen mit 15 Nationen die uns sich
uns angeschlossen haben die auf unsere
Initiative jetzt mitmachen bei diesem
großen Beschaffungsvorhaben werden wir
diese Lücken schließen nicht nur reden
nicht nur breitbeinig da stehen sondern
handeln das ist unsere Maxime meine
Damen und Herren
aber was wir auch machen ist endlich
auch dafür sorgen dass die Bundeswehr
entsprechend ausgestattet ist und ich
bin sehr froh über das 100 Milliarden
Sonderprogramm dass der Bundestag
beschlossen hat auch mit den Stimmen der
cdu/csu was ich allerdings nicht
verstehe ist dass sie sich
offensichtlich gar nicht mehr
zumindestens ein zwei die ja bei den
Beratungen auch dabei sein durften dass
sie sich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern
oh doch ich war von Anfang an dabei
sorry aber fragen Sie doch mal Herrn
badepol der war glaube ich dabei fragen
Sie mal ein Dobrind der war glaube ich
dabei sie war nicht dabei
aber das muss oder spricht jetzt aber
nicht für Herrn badepool wenn es dann
besser ausgegangen wäre wenn sie dabei
gewesen wäre was wir aber miteinander
vereinbart haben ist und deswegen greift
auch diese Kritik mit den zwei Prozent
nicht wir alle allen die dabei waren war
nämlich klar dass man im ersten Jahr
keineswegs auch nicht mit diesem
Sonderprogramm die zwei Prozent
erreichen kann und deswegen haben sie ja
sogar alle mitgestimmt als wir in
begleitet gesetzt festgelegt haben dass
wir zwei Prozent erreichen werden ja
aber über fünf Jahre im Durchschnitt
lesen Sie vielleicht noch mal das Gesetz
durch dass sie selbst mit beschlossen
haben und dass wir aus gutem Grund
genauso ausformuliert haben denn
zumindestens denjenigen die dabei waren
sie werden bestimmte Systeme nicht
einfach beim Baumarkt aus dem Regal
rausholen können also jetzt mal im Ernst
und deswegen war es klar dass man das
über ein bestimmten Zeitraum strecken
muss und genauso haben wir auch agiert
und jetzt höre ich oft in diesem
Sondervermögen ist ja nichts für
Munition vorgesehen ich kann Ihnen nur
raten schauen sie da rein es gibt ja
jetzt mittlerweile auch das
Begleitgremium und selbstverständlich
muss man immer auch überlegen was meine
ich denn mit Munition meinen sie da
kleines Kaliber also selbstverständlich
sind im Sondervermögen auch die
Bewaffnung beispielsweise der Drohnen
mit drin der 35 mit drin
Flugabwehrraketen drin und das fällt
natürlich alles unter den Begriffen
deswegen werden Millionen Milliarden
investiert in die Munition auch über
diese Sondervermögen ich weiß so viele
Fakten stören manchmal den Erzählfluss
aber manchmal kann es auch durchaus
sinnvoll sein darüber mal zu reden so
meine Damen und Herren und ähm
was ich an der Stelle aber auch sagen
muss ich bin sehr dankbar dass ich das
jetzt von verschiedener Seite heute hier
gehört habe dass dieser Haushalt in
Zukunft aufwachsen muss und das ist
wichtig und das ist richtig in diesem
Jahr haben wir die Möglichkeit über das
Sondervermögen und über die aktuelle
Situation ich sag's mal so über die
Runden zu kommen aber in Zukunft wird
sich das anders darstellen und Frau
Lötsch hat so gefragt was machen die
eigentlich mit 50 Milliarden so viel
Geld ich kann das mal ein bisschen
aufteilen ich habe eine
Personalverantwortung für
260.000 Menschen in diesem Ressort und
alleine für diese Personalverantwortung
muss ich jetzt und das wird deutlich
höher werden hoffentlich auch in den
nächsten Jahren weil das bedeutet dann
ja eine bessere Stellung für die für für
die Soldaten und auch die Zivil
Beschäftigten eine Personalverantwortung
für 260
000 Menschen das bedeutet 20 Milliarden
gehen von diesen 50 Milliarden
automatisch dafür nun müssen dafür
aufgewendet werden ich habe ganz ganz
viele Standorte Betriebe zu
sicherzustellen und gerade bei
steigenden Energiekosten wird das
natürlich auch mehr werden ist aber
jetzt schon 20 Milliarden wird aber mehr
werden das heißt der Teil den ich
dazwischen noch habe neben diesen
Wirtschaftsplan dem Sondervermögen der
wird weniger und deswegen kann ich sie
alle nur bitten wenn wir gemeinsam ernst
nehmen dass wir sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik in Zukunft nicht
mehr vernachlässigen nicht mehr
wegschauen nicht mehr die
Notwendigkeiten ignorieren dann muss
dieser Haushalt aufwachsen und ich freue
mich dass ich heute so viel Bereitschaft
dafür gehört habe werde sie da beim Wort
nehmen im Interesse der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten und im Interesse der Sicherheit
in diesem Land vielen Dank
sagt die bundesverteidigungsministerin
aber mit
50,12 Milliarden Euro für 2023 fällt der
Verteidigungsetat tatsächlich gegenüber
dem laufenden Jahr erstmal etwas
allerdings sollen weitere 8,4 Milliarden
Euro aus eben dem Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr im nächsten Jahr mindestens
verausgabt werden diese 100 Milliarden
sind ja nicht Bestandteil des Einzelnen
plans
meine Damen und Herren 9 Monate
zeitenwände Bundeswehr da möchte ich mit
einer Frage eröffnen wo ist sie hin die
zeitenwände des Bundeskanzlers Uwe Olaf
Scholz im Verteidigungsausschuss ist sie
bisher nicht angekommen die Presse sucht
ebenfalls nach ihr bei der Industrie ist
nichts angekommen und unsere Soldaten
haben nach neun Monaten auch nichts von
der Zeitenwende in ihren Kasernen
gesehen Scholz zeitenwände es gibt sie
nicht und auch
auch nicht nach ihrem gerade gehörten
Erklärungsversuch Frau Ministerin die
Wahrheit ist zur Verteidigung unseres
Landes schafft es die Bundesregierung
100 Milliarden Euro Schulden zu machen
aber sie schafft es nicht das Geld für
unsere Streitkräfte auszugeben was die
Bundesregierung unserer Bundeswehr antut
ist Sabotage Sabotage durch Unfähigkeit
liebe
Kollegen was könnte eine willige und
fähige Bundesregierung mit 100
Milliarden alles machen viele Schäden
die der Bundeswehr in den letzten
Jahrzehnten zugefügt wurden könnten
damit repariert werden es war übrigens
diese Aussicht auf eine materielle Wende
bei der Bundeswehr warum eine Mehrheit
dem Sondervermögen zustimmte jetzt aber
zeigt sich dass die 100 geladen
schuldengeld dahin schmelzen wie Schnee
in der Sonne und die Gründe sind alle
hausgemacht erstens durch die
galapierende Inflation verringert sich
die Kaufkraft der Sondervermögens in den
kommenden fünf Jahren auf 69 Milliarden
das heißt 31 Milliarden Kaufkraft
verbrannt zweitens der Zinssprung für
das geliehene Geld schlägt beim
Sondervermögen ebenfalls voll ins Kontor
allein in den sechs Monaten dieses
Jahres gehen 3008 Millionen Euro nur für
Zinsen drauf für diese Summe könnte das
Verteidigungsministerium 20 neue
Panzerhaubitzen kaufen aber das
Verteidigungsministerium kauft keine
Panzerhaubitzen genauso wenig wie schwer
der Transporthubschrauber Boxer für die
mittleren Kräfte oder die enorm wichtige
Flugabwehr stattdessen zahlt das
Verteidigungsministerium Zinsen mit
Zinsen können unsere Soldaten nicht
kämpfen auf den
auf den dritten Punkt macht uns
freundlicherweise Staatssekretärin
Möller im letzten Ausschuss aufmerksam
die Schwäche des Euro jeder rüstungskauf
in den USA wie die F35 oder der schwere
Transporthubschrauber wird
logischerweise in US-Dollar abgerechnet
durch den weichen Euro gibt es immer
weniger Ausrüstung fürs Geld in den USA
ihre katastrophale Finanzpolitik greift
nicht nur unseren Wohlstand an sondern
auch unsere Verteidigungsbereitschaft
vierter und letzter Grund für die
Schmelze des Sondervermögens ist das
total überforderte Beschaffungssystem
der Bundeswehr alle
verteidigungsministerinnen der letzten
neun Jahre versuchten sich an einer
Reform alle sind gescheitert Frau
Lambrecht selbst hat den Versuch einer
Reform aufgegeben was die
Bundesregierung mit dem Sondervermögen
macht ist eine
die Vernichtung und die Bundeswehr wird
auch in Zukunft nicht
verteidigungsbereit sein meine Damen und
Herren die Lage ist Verfahren für jeden
Verteidigungspolitiker egal von welcher
Partei ich sage Ihnen was ich in dieser
Lage tun würde ich würde klare
Prioritäten setzen Waffen und Munition
bestellen so schnell es geht die wird
deutsche wehrtechnische Industrie kann
liefern sie wartet nur auf Bestellung
und ich würde ins Risiko gehen mich über
das Vergaberecht hinwegsetzen dem
rüstungsamt Beine machen es auf klagen
ankommen lassen echte politische Führung
setzt den Willen zur Umsetzung voraus es
bedeutet dass wohl der Bundeswehr und
unser Bundesrepublik im Blick zu haben
und für notwendige Entscheidung zur Not
auch persönlich gerade zu stehen danke
schön
Rüdiger Lukassen war das für die
afd-fraktion und ihm folgt jetzt hier in
der Aussprache zum Einzelplan
Verteidigungen zum sogenannten Wehretat
Niklas Wagner
er sitzt für die Grünen im
Verteidigungsausschuss ist aber auch
Europa politischer Sprecher sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin Frau werbeauftragte
sehr geehrte Soldatinnen und Soldaten
auf der Tribüne liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es ist unsere gemeinsame
Aufgabe von Regierung und Parlament die
Bundeswehr entsprechend ihrem Auftrag
und ihren Aufgaben personell und
materiell bestmöglich auszustatten das
ist keine Sache von Aufrüstung sondern
von Ausrüstung und genau diese gute
Ausrüstung treiben wir mit dem
Einzelplan 14 für das Haushaltsjahr 23
weiter voran und das ist gut so
der furchtbare
der furchtbare Angriffskrieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine hat uns in diesem Jahr
alle erschüttert und wir stehen weiter
unverrückbar an der Seite der mutigen
Menschen in der Ukraine und werden das
ukrainische Militär weiterhin
bestmöglich mit Waffen und Munitionen
unterstützen
diese Unterstützung hat uns aber einmal
mehr die drastischen Lücken in der
Bundes in der Bundeswehr vor Augen
geführt die uns die Vorgängerregierung
hinterlassen hat gerade wenn sie auch
aus der Unionsfraktion sehr laut nach
mehr Waffen für die Ukraine rufen müssen
sie sich auch klar machen dass die
Zeitenwende für die Soldatinnen der
Bundeswehr bislang bedeutet dass sie
heute mit weniger Gerät und weniger
Munition üben als zu Beginn des Krieges
in der Ukraine und das ist ein Dilemma
das wir nun mit einer tiefgreifenden
beschaffungsreform auflösen die dafür
sorgt dass die abgegebenen Systeme aus
dem her aus dem Sanitätsdienst aus der
Streitkräftebasis schnellstmöglich
Nachbarschaft werden es geht ja auch um
Vertrauen dass Zeiten wenn wir natürlich
mehr bedeutet als Winterjacken und
Nässeschutz
mit dem
Regierungswechsel haben wir aber bereits
die größte beschaffungsreform seit
langem umgesetzt endlich wird nicht mehr
nach Wahlkreis wünschen einzelner
Abgeordneter beschafft sondern nach der
Maßgabe die Einsatzbereitschaft der
Bundeswehr zu erhöhen und die gegenüber
der nato-vereinbarten Ziele einzuhalten
und wir werden
und wir werden dafür Sorge tragen dass
diese zeitenwände in der
Beschaffungspolitik bei allen
Verantwortlichen ankommen wird wir haben
unsere Nato-Partner zugesagt eine
einsatzbereite die Vision bereits im
Jahr 2025 statt wie ursprünglich geplant
erst 2027 bereitzustellen umso wichtiger
ist nun auch ein forderungscontrolling
der Haushaltsmittel um sicherzustellen
dass das Mehr an Haushaltsmitteln an
Verteidigungsausgaben auch zu einem Mehr
an Einsatzbereitschaft führt und wir die
zehnte panzerdivision in Veitshöchheim
auch wirklich bis 2025 einsatzbereit
machen schließlich ist das Geld in
diesem Haushalt Steuergeld und wir
müssen es so effizient als möglich
einsetzen wir haben viele Projekte des
Heeres für die Digitalisierung
landbasierte Operationen oder den Namen
nicht-
im Sanitätsdienst und 1900 neue
Dienstposten für die Streitkräftebasis
sind wichtige Schritte auf dem Weg zu
einer einsatzbereiten Division denn ohne
Sanität und Logistik kommt auch das her
nicht weit das her die einsatzbereite
Division 2025 muss aber auch schießen
können dafür braucht sie Munition die
Munitionsbestände der Bundeswehr sind
seit Jahren auf ein Minimum reduziert
worden von der nato-vorgabe des 30 Tage
Vorrats ist die Bundeswehr heute noch
sehr weit entfernt die Munition reichte
im Ernstfall für zwei Tage hört man an
vielen Stellen das ist nicht nur aus
militärischer Sicht sehr schlicht sehr
schlecht stellt uns als Deutschland auch
in ein ungutes politisches Licht bei
unseren Partnern und deshalb haben wir
auch die ursprünglichen im Haushalt
eingeplanten eine Milliarde Euro für
Munition noch mal um über eine Milliarde
erhöht und deswegen möchte ich auch in
Richtung der Unionsfraktion noch mal
sagen wenn Markus Söder jetzt in Bayern
die Nacken aufbläst und mehr Munition
für die Bundeswehr fordert dann möge er
bitte auch sicherstellen dass seine
staatlichen Bauämter auch die
notwendigen Munitionsdepots bauen die
Ertüchtigung
die Ertüchtigung der Infrastruktur in
der Bundeswehr scheiterte in den
vergangenen Jahren nie an mangelnden
Bundesmitteln sondern wohl mehr daran
dass sich die CSU in Bayern mehr mit dem
Ausbau unnötiger Umgehungsstraßen als
mit der Sanierung wichtiger
militärischer Infrastruktur beschäftigt
hat
und auch wenn die bauhoheit in der
Zuständigkeit der Länder liegt haben wir
natürlich dennoch gehandelt und Leiden
und Bauingenieure aus der Bundeswehr an
die landesbauverwaltungen aus um den
massiven Investitionsstau abzubauen auch
hier handelt die Ampelkoalition alle
Parteien der demokratischen Mitte alle
Häuser alle Ämter alle Abteilungen
müssen in und nach der zeitenwände
zusammenarbeiten für die Sicherheit
unserer Soldatinnen für unsere
Sicherheit als Land aber auch für unsere
Partner und Verbündeten in NATO und EU
ich komme zum Schluss wir müssen Wort
halten Verbindlichkeit zeigen Vertrauen
weiter ausbauen dieser Haushalt 23 ist
ein Schritt auf diesem Weg vielen Dank
90 Sekunden hier Niklas Wagener
jetzt hören wir hier als nächsten Redner
den verteidigungspolitischen Sprecher
der Liberalen das ist Alexander Müller
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Jahr 2022 ist eine Zäsur in
unserer Geschichte aber es ist auch das
Jahr der Bundeswehr endlich wird der
wegbereitet für die Vollausstattung
unserer Armee und für die
Einsatzbereitschaft der ganzen Truppe
jahrelang jahrzehntelang wurde bei der
Verteidigung nur gespart Fähigkeiten
wurden aufgegeben Standorte wurden
geschlossen und jetzt ist es endlich
gelungen den Kurs wieder zu korrigieren
ich zähle mal auf wir haben das 100
milliardenprogramm mit dringenden
Investitionen für unsere Truppe auf den
Weg gebracht wir haben die Nachfolge für
den alten Tornado endlich geregelt das
was sie nämlich nicht hinbekommen haben
wir haben die persönliche
Schutzausrüstung für die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten im Volumen von 2,4 Milliarden
beschlossen und auf den Weg gebracht wir
haben den dringend nötigen schweren
Transporthubschrauber bestellt wir haben
die Beschaffung deutlich beschleunigt
mit dem
bundeswehrbeschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
und das war nur der Anfang das Programm
geht weiter
wir investieren 20 Milliarden alleine in
die Digitalisierung in die
Führungsfähigkeit der Bundeswehr in der
Schlussphase beim Haushalt haben wir
noch mal 18 Millionen extra draufgelegt
für die digitale Gesundheitsakte der
Bundeswehr wir haben die bewaffneten
Drohnen endlich auf den Weg gebracht was
sie nicht geschafft haben und dazu kommt
wir haben eine regelmäßige Evaluierung
aller unserer Auslandseinsätze und auch
das rechtzeitige stoppen das Verhindern
von permanentmandaten und auch das ist
effektiver Mitteleinsatz von
Steuergeldern und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich habe leider nur drei
Minuten Redezeit ich könnte weiter
aufzählen aber ich will eines ganz
besonders noch betonen der Einzelplan 14
muss auf mittlere Sicht unbedingt weiter
aufwachsen wenn wir dauerhaft das zwei
Prozent Ziel erreichen wollen so wie es
unser Bundeskanzler heute morgen an
dieser Stelle wieder gesagt hat und das
müssen wir auch rechtzeitig angehen
bevor das Sondervermögen aufgebraucht
ist und Liebe Union mit Zwischenrufen
sind sie ja heute ganz groß wenn man
ihnen zuhört bekommt man heute den
Eindruck oder ein unbedarfter Zuhörer
könnte diesen Eindruck bekommen sie
hätten sich in den letzten Jahren hier
für das 2% Ziel an dieser Stelle
eingesetzt das möge im
Koalitionsausschuss vielleicht gewesen
sein an dieser Stelle haben sie es nicht
getan das will ich nun mal festhalten
und wenn man den Kollegen badeful zuhört
dann könnte man den Eindruck bekommen
unter Frau von der Leyen oder unter Frau
Karrenbauer seien die Läger für Munition
der Artillerie voll gewesen jeder hier
im Haus weiß wie die Realität ist und
woran es liegt dass diese Lager heute
allesamt leer sind
und der Kollege Carsten klein hat es
eben ausgerechnet wir werden im 2023 25
Prozent mehr investieren in die
Bundeswehr als es in ihrer
mittelfristigen Finanzplanung drin war
der Kollege Ingo gerischens nennt das
ein Desaster ja sie haben eine Menge in
Haushaltsberatung tolle Anträge für
Steigerungen gestellt aber keinen
einzigen unterfüttert oder finanziert
als wir noch in der Opposition waren
haben wir wenigstens seriös jeden Antrag
gegenfinanziert sie gehen heute das
Prinzip Weihnachtsmann man hofft dass
der Weihnachtsmann mit dem Geldbeutel
kommt und das irgendwo vorbei bringt das
aber inflationsfördern denn das erhöht
die Geldmenge liebe Freunde unsere
fortschrittskoalition macht endlich
ernst mit der Vollausstattung unserer
Bundeswehr und das gebietet auch der
Respekt vor unseren Soldatinnen und
Soldaten bei denen ich mich heute ganz
besonders für ihren Einsatz bedanken
möchte vielen Dank
der die Union hatte unter anderem in den
Haushaltsberatungen beantragt den veta
um 3,9 Milliarden Euro zu erhöhen und
schneller Geld aus dem Sondervermögen zu
investieren um das auch für sie
symbolisch wichtige zwei Prozent Ziel
der NATO eben zu erreichen diese
Vorschläge die sind im
Haushaltsausschuss abgelehnt worden die
Union hat jetzt noch mal das Wort
Florian Hahn
Zuschauer vor allem bei dieser bei
diesem Tagesordnungspunkt natürlich auch
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten die zuhören
Friedrich Merz hat es heute bereits
richtig gesagt die zeitenwände von Rede
von Scholz am 27.02 hat viele
Erwartungen geweckt doch die
Ampelkoalition ist sich treu geblieben
und hat alle enttäuscht und von den
verheißungsvollen reden bleiben am Ende
viele Worte auch heute nach dieser
Diskussion aber wenig Taten übrig und
mit Blick auf den Verteidigungshaushalt
ist klar die Verteidigungsministerin
hängt sich nicht rein die Ampel liefert
nicht und Olaf Scholz ist wortbrüche der
Bundeskanzler hat am 27.02 an dieser
Stelle versprochen von jetzt an mehr als
zwei Prozent des BIP für Verteidigungen
auszugeben und am Ende sind mit dem
jetzt vorgelegten verteidigungsgetan nur
1,6 % rausgekommen inklusive der
Ausgaben aus dem Sondervermögen Herr
Bundeskanzler sie wir haben hier ihr
Versprechen gebrochen und Kanzler Scholz
hat
von Kanzler Scholz hat auf der
bundeswehrtagung am 16 September
gegenüber den Soldatinnen und Soldaten
der Bundeswehr mit Blick auf die zwei
Prozent folgendes Versprechen gegeben
sie können damit planen sie können mich
beim Wort nehmen Herr Bundeskanzler sie
haben noch einmal ihr Versprechen
gebrochen und wir müssen leider ganz
nüchtern feststellen dass Wort das
Bundeskanzlers gegenüber unserer
Bundeswehr ist offensichtlich nichts
wert das ist respektlos gegenüber
unseren Soldatinnen und Soldaten
gegenüber dem Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und wir
haben fragt man sich wie konnte das
eigentlich passieren wir haben sich
offensichtlich hier haben sich
offensichtlich genau die Kräfte in der
Regierungskoalition durchgesetzt die
bereits in der Vergangenheit dafür
verantwortlich waren dass die Bundeswehr
nicht die Mittel bekommen hat die sie
braucht und damit meine ich unseren
ehemaligen Koalitionspartner nämlich sie
die SPD die
älteste bereit Deutschlands scheint
nämlich an Altersdemenz zu bleiben es
ist wirklich unverfroren liebe Kollegen
und auch liebe Frau Ministerin es ist
wirklich unverfroren dass sie die
hoodsbär haben ausgerechnet uns der
Union die Unterversorgung der Bundeswehr
in die Schuhe zu schieben sie waren es
doch sie waren es doch die jedes neue
Waffensystem ich erinnere mich nur an
die bewaffnungsfähige Drohne und jeden
zusätzlichen Cent für die Bundeswehr in
den letzten acht Jahren bekämpft haben
und falls sie sich tatsächlich und falls
Sie das tatsächlich vergessen haben
sollten will ich Ihnen gerne helfen ich
habe hier meinen Ausdruck tagesschau.de
vom April 2019 zwei Prozent geht es um
die zwei Prozent wir haben in
Deutschland andere Sorgen als sinnlose
Aufrüstung
spd-vize-chef Ralf Degner ließ keinen
Zweifel daran was er von den Berichten
hielt die CSU als möglicher
Koalitionspartner wolle zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes für Verteidigung
ausgeben zweites Beispiel der Kollege
war der cool hat das schon angesprochen
ein Tag vor der historischen Rede des
Bundeskanzler und zwei Tage nach
Kriegsbeginn groß Kölner Rundschau
Mützenich will deutsche militärausgabe
nicht weiter erhöhen aber immer noch
mehr Aufrüstung kann nicht die Antwort
sein so wird er dort zitiert und das
dritte Beispiel liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in der letzten Legislatur hat
mir durchweg das Problem dass die
mittelfristige Finanzplanung und Herr
Klein sie werden sich erinnern weil sie
das nämlich in den Debatten immer
richtigerweise angeprangert haben dass
die mittlere Finanzplanung keinerlei
aufwuchs dass dort keinerlei auf uns
wieder gespiegelt war damit konnte weder
das BMVg noch die Industrie noch die
Bündnispartner verlässlich planen
verantwortlich dafür war einzig allein
der damalige Finanzminister Olaf Scholz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und hier
wurde heute an diesem Tisch so viel
Unsinn erzählt von von den Mitgliedern
der Ampel Koalition da will ich schon
mal aufräumen lieber Herr Müller ich
schätze ja wirklich normalerweise sehr
aber dass sie hier sich hinstellen und
das ist eben genau der Trugschluss es
ist eben nichts bestellt worden aus dem
Sondervermögen und der Schwere
Transporthubschrauber ist eben nicht
bestellt worden so wie Sie es gerade
hier behauptet haben das ist nämlich
tatsächlich die Wahrheit und lieber Herr
Klein wenn sie sagen Mensch das ein
super Haushalt und es geht aufmerksam
will ich mal feststellen eins im Bereich
Beschaffung das sind die Investitionen
hängt dieser Haushalt 2023 um 1,8
Milliarden hinter dem von 22 hinterher
es passiert eben viel zu wenig es geht
nicht aufwärts mit der Ausrüstung und
mit der Beschaffungen für unsere
Bundeswehr und lieber Herr Schäfer von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen das ist schon sehr
mutig dass sie das Thema Munition hier
ansprechen dass sie das Hören Munition
ansprechen ich kann Ihnen folgendes
sagen der Generalinspektor und die
Ministerin haben beide Anfang diesen
Jahres festgestellt mit Blick auf die
NATO Verpflichtungen und das war vor dem
Krieg mit Blick auf die NATO
Verpflichtung es fehlen uns 20
Milliarden für Munition inzwischen ist
der Krieg dazu gekommen inzwischen haben
wir tonnenweise Munition richtiger Weise
an die Ukraine abgegeben inzwischen ist
klar dass die NATO hat neue Strategien
festgelegt die beinhalten dass wir noch
mehr Bedarf haben und allein schon für
das Thema auch Übung und Ausbildung und
jetzt steht in diesem Haushalt eine
Milliarde drin für Munition
bei dem bei dem Bedarf von 20 Milliarden
kann ich nur sagen brauchen wir mehr als
20 Jahre und das tatsächlich zu
beschaffen was wir heute schon bräuchten
so sieht die Realität aus und so sieht
der aktuelle Haushalt bei ihnen
tatsächlich aus
und ich frag mich ganz ehrlich wo ist
eigentlich der Respekt gebliebene
Respekt in die SPD hier tatsächlich
immer propler proklamiert hat in ihrem
in ihrem Wahlkampf dass dieser Haushalt
ist kein Respekt gegenüber den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten das ist kein
Respekt gegenüber den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern gegenüber den Wählern sie haben
ein Versprechen hier abgegeben halten
sie sich gefälligst an dieses
Versprechen zwei Prozent dauerhaft für
die Bundeswehr und die 100 Milliarden so
schnell wie möglich ausgeben
hier noch mal betont hat das zieht sich
hier
über den Tag hinweg dieser
Haushaltsberatung von der Generaldebatte
heute morgen
bis jetzt zur Debatte rund um den
Verteidigungshaushalt hören wir jetzt
für die Sozialdemokraten den nächsten
Redner Kevin leiser wird das sein
Kollegen sehr geehrte Frau
werbeauftragte liebe Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger unsere sicherheitspolitische
Lage ist geprägt von Desinformation
Cyberangriffen den Missbrauch von
Energie als Waffe und der Gefährdung
unserer Infrastruktur die Bundeswehr ist
mehr denn je Teil öffentlicher
Daseinsvorsorge die Stärkung einer
Daseinsvorsorge ist eine
ursozialdemokratische Aufgabe
Verteidigung Politik ist also zu Recht
sozialdemokratischer Markenkern ich
ich bin sehr dankbar dass in diesen
herausfordernden Zeiten
Sozialdemokratien und Sozialdemokraten
in dieser Regierung die innere äußere
und soziale Sicherheit Deutschlands
stärken
in den vergangenen Monaten konnten wir
in unserer fortschrittskoalition große
Meilensteine zur Stärkung unserer
Sicherheit verzeichnen die Ausgabe der
persönlichen Ausrüstung unserer
Soldatinnen und Soldaten läuft bis 2025
ist die Vollausstattung der Truppe mit
Rucksäcken Schutzrechten und
gefechtsheim abgeschlossen das haben
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten mehr als
verdient
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht hat
das territoriale Führungskommando der
Bundeswehr aufgestellt
unsere Verteidigungsministerin und unser
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz haben bereits
mehr als haben bereits 15 Staaten aus
West und Osteuropa zusammengeführt für
ein europäisches Luftverteidigungssystem
die Tornado Nachfolge und die
Beschaffung des schweren
transporthubschraubers sind geklärt
Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
konnten nun auch große Fortschritte bei
fkas dem europäischen Kampfflugzeug der
nächsten Generation verzeichnen was für
eine hervorragende Bilanz
cdu/csu versuchen diese Erfolge
kleinzureden sie meinen wir würden zu
wenig für die Beschaffung von Munition
tun abgesehen davon dass angesichts
knapper Produktionskapazitäten und
begrenzter Lagermöglichkeit Münch
einfach auf den Bestellbutton klicken
können wir arbeiten ein Lösungen
und Herr Hahn ich helfe Ihnen gerne auf
die Sprünge mit der Erinnerung und zwar
mit dem Rückblick ins Jahr 2011 denn vor
knapp 11 Jahren hat der
spd-verteidigungspolitiker Rainer Arnold
damals Opposition die cdu/csu geführte
Regierung davor gewarnt die Bundeswehr
kaputt zu sparen
2011 hielt er hier an diesem Pult eine
Rede aus der ich gerne zitieren möchte
Zitat die Finanzpolitik schlägt
inzwischen auf die Einsätze durch dafür
dass die Anzahl der Flugstunden der
ohnehin wenigen Hubschrauber aufgrund
des Geldes dramatisch beschnitten wird
tragen Sie Herr Minister de Messias die
Verantwortung Zitat Ende und jetzt
halten Sie sich fest Zitat wenn in
Afghanistan Munition fehlt dann ist dies
ihre Verantwortung Zitat Ende wissen Sie
wie damals die cdu/csu regiert hat da
gab es Zwischenrufe und die Zwischenrufe
waren Zitat langweilig Zitat Ende somit
wir haben ihnen gesagt was passieren
kann das zu wenig Munition da ist ist
sie antworteten mit langweilig sie haben
es einfach ignoriert herr Arnold hat vor
Jahren den Munitionsmangel angeklagt
danach folgten Jahre der Untätigkeit von
cdu/csu ohne Verantwortung ohne
Engagement ohne Entscheidungen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von CDU CSU ihr
Gebaren ist leider unterirdisch
scheinheilig
nachdem das geklärt ist wenden wir uns
wieder der Zukunft zu Intention in den
Dimensionen Cyber und Weltraum müssen
wir uns besser aufstellen die Dimension
Cyber hat für uns Priorität Kollege
Müller hat es auch erwähnt wir werden 20
Milliarden aus dem Sondervermögen
ausgeben für Führungsfähigkeit
Funkgeräte serverkommunikationsmittel in
der Dimension Cyber müssen wir uns
organisatorisch besser aufstellen im
nationalen cyberabwehrzentrum in Bonn
arbeiten die Bundeswehr mehrere
Bundesbehörden und auch zwei
Bundesländer daran Informationen über
Cyberangriffe zusammenzutragen wir
benötigen aber eine Zentralstelle die
anderen Stellen Weisungen erteilen kann
und da bin ich sehr froh dass
Innenministerin NC Faser sich genau
dafür einsetzt
die Bundeswehr und das deutsche luft-
und Raumfahrtzentrum betreiben gemeinsam
das weltraumlagezentrum in Uedem hier
hat sich die Zivil militärische
Zusammenarbeit gewährt wir stellen
Mittel bereit um die Aufklärung von
weltraumobjekten und ihre Bewegungen
wesentlich zu verbessern Deutschland hat
es Potenzial in der Dimension Weltraum
an den Partner für unsere europäischen
Verbündeten zu fungieren dieses
Potenzial gilt es zu nutzen
die Bundeswehr ist mehr denn je Teil
öffentlicher Daseinsvorsorge eine gute
Daseinsvorsorge ist eine
ursozialdemokratische Aufgabe wir
stärken in unserer fortschrittskoalition
die Sicherheit Deutschlands
2022/2023 und auch in den nächsten
Jahren vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
und verbindest 90 die grüne hat das Wort
die Kollegin sarani
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen sehr geehrte werbeauftragte
meine Damen und Herren am 3 Juni hat
dieses Haus mit großer Mehrheit das
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
beschlossen unter dem Eindruck des
russischen Angriffs gegen die Ukraine
hat man sich auch in der Bundesrepublik
die Frage gestellt ob wir für eine
dauerhaft konfrontative Beziehung zu
Russland militärisch gut genug
aufgestellt sind und diese Frage wurde
mit Nein beantwortet ich sag's noch mal
deutlicher einen Angriff Russland gegen
die NATO
Gott bewahrungs davor würde auch die
Bundeswehr schnell an die Grenzen
bringen rein materiell das
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr ein
historisch einmaliger Vorgang soll das
beheben es ist ein Vertrauensvorschuss
für das BMVg die Bundeswehr die
Rüstungsindustrie und auch uns als
Parlament die Bevölkerung vertraut
darauf dass das Sondervermögen so rasch
wie möglich zu einer Verbesserung der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der
Bundesrepublik führt im Großen und
Ganzen sage ich zu Recht gemeinsam
werden wir den Erwartungen gerecht so
gut es geht der Kanzler hat heute morgen
auch angesprochen zaubern kann im BMVg
niemand und Zeitenwende ist kein springt
aber bei einer Sache wunder ich mich
doch sehr und ich meine nicht die
Tatsache dass die vorhabensplanung noch
mal neu gemacht werden musste weil bei
einer Inflation von zehn Prozent der
Bundesrechnungshof zurecht anmerkte dass
die ursprünglich veranschlagten Projekte
über das Sondervermögen nicht zu 100
Prozent zu finanzieren sind da muss ich
auch die Kritik der Opposition teilweise
zurückweisen es ist kein planlos Fehler
war ist dass die Inflation auch in dem
Bereich keinen Halt macht und im Rahmen
des Möglichen hat das Haus hier wie ich
finde sachgerecht priorisiert und uns
das Parlament auch umfassend informiert
dafür vielen Dank
die Debatte darüber das wurde schon
mehrfach angesprochen wie das
Fähigkeitsprofil der Bundeswehr trotz
der nötigen Verschiebung vollständig
erreicht werden kann müssen wir zu
gegebenen Zeitpunkt noch einmal führen
klar ist auch Geld allein wird die
Fähigkeitslücken der Bundeswehr nicht
schließen wir müssen es auch effizienter
zum Beispiel durch gemeinsame
Beschaffung mit anderen Europäern
ausgeben wobei den Beschaffungen selbst
priorisieren
doch was brauchen wir damit wir sofort
die Kampfkraft für den Ernstfall
verbessern schon im Frühjahr war klar
dass wir auch stark in Munition
investieren müssen der Generalinspektion
sprach davon dass bis 2031 und 20
Milliarden da dafür zu veranschlagen
werden mit den Abgaben an die Ukraine
die ich ausdrücklich befürworte ist
diese Herausforderung noch einmal
gewachsen das war im Haushaltsentwurf
der uns zunächst hier im Parlament
vorgelegt wurde nicht sichtbar der
Haushaltsausschuss hat deshalb dafür
gesorgt dass das BMVg in den nächsten
Jahren eine ganze Milliarde mehr zu
Beschaffung von Munition zur Verfügung
hat
doch die Defizite bei der Munition der
Kollege Sprache ist ja gerade schon an
sind nicht von gestern auf heute
entstanden sondern waren auch der Union
wohlbekannt und ich bin sehr geehrte
kollegevoll Herr Florian Hahn schon auch
etwas verwundert mit welchem Schutz pesy
jedes Mal sich wieder hier ins Pool
stellen und so tun als hätten sie nichts
damit zu tun
mit der Bundeswehrreform 20.11 wurden
zahlreiche Munitionsdepots und
Materiallager der Bundeswehr geschlossen
geplant war das Vorhaben von Guttenberg
durchgeführt wurde es von de Maizière
nicht korrigiert von Frau von der Leyen
und auch nicht von Frau Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer
das mag der Fall sein nur da kann ich
Ihnen eine Sache zu sagen wenn Herr Hahn
sich hier hinstellt und darüber
lamentiert warum denn nie andere dafür
gesprochen hätten mehr Geld in die
Bundeswehr zu investieren es ist nicht
auch die Union die mit ihren Wahlkreis
Geschenken wo dieses Budget als eine Art
Sondervermögen für die unionswahlkreise
teilweise betrachtet wurde nicht auch
mit an der Skepsis nicht auch mit an der
Skepsis gearbeitet die einer pauschalen
Erhöhung natürlich im Gegenstande
ja jetzt wird es ernst ist schon die
ganze Zeit ernst
ich kann verstehen dass die Frau
Ministerin zu den genauen Beständen der
Munition keine Auskunft geben wollen das
würde ich auch nicht raten dass das viel
zu riskant aber wenn ich alleine die
Liste dessen was wir ein Munition an die
Ukraine abgegeben haben neben die
bmf-vorlagen die wir in diesem Jahr
bisher bekommen haben oder schon
angekündigt sind halte dann ergibt sich
daraus eben doch eine Lücke in der
Planung insbesondere bei der Munition es
kommt jetzt auf sie an Frau Ministerin
und auf ihr Haus hier schnell
nachzusteuern ich bin zuversichtlich
dass ihnen der Haushalt dafür den
nötigen Rahmen gewährt
die verteidigungspolitische Sprecherin
von Bündnisse 90 die Grünen ja und auch
sie hat die Defizite bei der Munition
angesprochen die ja hier doch schon
mehrfach Thema waren in dieser
Aussprache Nils Gründer hören wir jetzt
als nächsten für die FDP-Fraktion
spricht er
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau werbeauftragte liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen
morgens sind es auf den Tag neun Monate
neun Monate seit dem Putin seine
Invasion der Ukraine begann
neun Monate die auch von uns als
deutsche ein grundlegendes Umdenken
fordern jetzt liegt es in der
Verantwortung der Politik unserer
Verantwortung diese zeitenwände
kontinuierlich in unseren
Verteidigungsausgaben abzubilden und auf
dem starken Start von 58 Milliarden Euro
aufzubauen
und nun mal als Erinnerung
jede Fraktion dieses Hauses ob Regierung
ob Opposition jeder einzelne von uns ist
für unsere Soldaten und Soldaten
mitverantwortlich
es freut mich zu sehen dass die
Koalition mit dem Sondervermögen so
schnell auf diese aktuelle
Ausnahmesituation reagiert hat ein
längst notwendiger Schritt durch welchen
wir beispielsweise die geplante
Vollausstattung unserer Truppe also
Schutzwesten gefechtshelme
kampfbekleidung und Rucksäcke von 2031
auf 20 25 vorziehen konnten ein Erfolg
der zeigt dass die Investitionen dort
ankommen wo sie am nötigsten gebraucht
werden
und es müssen sich mal vorstellen unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten es leiden
teilweise immer noch unter der absolut
untragbaren Situation dass ihre
Ausstattung zum Teil aus privaten
Mitteln finanzieren müssen
unsere gut unsere ersten Schritte waren
so müssen noch viele weitere folgen denn
eine Verteidigungshaushalt ist bereits
jetzt überstrapaziert das Sondervermögen
fließt in die ausrüstungsvorhaben das
ist zwar notwendig aber denkt nur einen
Bruchteil der akuten Bedürfnisse der
Bundeswehr so führt die Beschaffung
zusätzlicher Munition zwangsläufig zu
einer notwendigen Ausweitung der
Munitionslager mehr Panzer bedeuten mehr
Personal und mehr ausgebildete
Entschuldigung mehr Panzer bedeuten mehr
Erwartungen und mehr ausgebildetes
Personal
unser festes Ziel muss daher bleiben
Aufstockung des verteidigungshaushaltes
um endlich und tatsächlich das 2% Ziel
zu erreichen und nach dem Sondervermögen
ein nachhaltigen Betrieb der Bundeswehr
auch zu garantieren
dazu kommt unsere Verpflichtung ein
Fünftel unseres Verteidigungsbudgets in
großbeschaffungen Entwicklung und
Forschung zu investieren und das ist nur
möglich wenn nach Personal und
Instandhaltungskosten auch noch genug
Geld für diese Investitionen übrig
bleibt ich glaube uns ist mittlerweile
hier allen bewusst das Sicherheit und
Frieden einen Preis haben
mir ist wichtig heute herauszustellen
dass es unsere Aufgabe ist durch weitere
Investitionen eben diese Sicherheit
diesen Frieden und deren Garanten unsere
Bundeswehr zu sichern unsere Koalition
hatten dieser Sache einen starken Start
hingelegt es ist aber das erste Anfang
vielen Dank
am Anfang seiner Rede hat Nils Gründer
daran erinnert dass jeder einzelne jeder
einzelne Abgeordnete für die Bundeswehr
hier verantwortlich ist denn bevor die
Bundeswehr beispielsweise ins Ausland
geht muss der Bundestag zustimmen aber
zum Beispiel entscheidet der Bundestag
eben auch über den Verteidigungshaushalt
auch deshalb ist die Bundeswehr eine
parlamentarmee
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren um es einmal
vorweg zu sagen dieser
Haushaltsentwurf wird den
sicherheitspolitischen Ansprüchen nicht
gerecht denn von den 100 Milliarden Euro
ist bisher nichts umgesetzt worden der
Einzelplan 14 wird sogar abgesenkt auf
einem Niveau eingefroren für die
nächsten Jahre meine Damen und Herren
verantwortungsvolle Sicherheitspolitik
sieht anders aus
die militärischen Beschaffung sind
abgesenkt worden von fast 10 Milliarden
auf unter 8 Milliarden Investitionen für
Forschung und Entwicklungen sind gesenkt
worden dabei ist es doch offen kundig
dass wir in Technologien investieren
müssten wie beispielsweise responsive
space oder auch Hyperschall um an der
Spitze der Technologie zu stehen und
auch um etwas mehr in die Waagschale
unserer NATO einbringen zu können dieser
haushaltspolitische Vorgehensweise und
der Berücksichtigung einer starken
Inflation der Preissteigerung eines
Wechselkurses dies alles macht deutlich
es wäre viel mehr Eile geboten es wäre
Entscheidungsfreude geboten nichts davon
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin können wir
feststellen wir können in diesem
Haushalt so nicht zustimmen
stattdessen versuchen Sie hier wie in
einem ampelchor Platzhalter zu setzen
Dinge in Aussicht zu stellen zu
suggerieren sie würden längst
Entscheidungen getroffen haben die
allesamt nicht stimmen gemessen an dem
was am 27 februar von dieser Stelle aus
vom Bundeskanzler gesagt worden ist
können wir sagen nichts davon wird
umgesetzt entweder die
Regierungskoalition folgt dem
Bundeskanzler nicht oder der
Bundeskanzler kann sich nicht
durchsetzen oder die Bundesregierung und
die Regierungskoalition beide scheitern
an den eigenen Ansprüchen und nehmen die
sicherheitspolitische Rolle nicht wahr
meine Damen und Herren
und wir nehmen die Diskussion als
cdu/csu gerne auf wir stellen uns der
Verantwortung denn als Opposition haben
wir zugestimmt bei der
Grundgesetzänderung zum 100
milliarden-programm und als
Regierungspartei haben wir deutlich
gemacht dass wir mehr finanzielle Mittel
brauchen nach der Annektion der Krim und
wir haben es geschafft in den letzten
vier Jahren den Haushalt um 30 Prozent
zu erhöhen aber wer stand denn damals
für mehr auf der Bremse es ist der
heutige Bundeskanzler und der damalige
Finanzminister Scholz meine Damen und
Herren das müssen sie sich einfach
anhören und machen Sie doch einfach Ihre
Regierungspolitik und hören Sie auf
immer darauf zu verweisen was alles
hätte besser werden müssen sie sind
jetzt die Ampel sie müssen regieren und
das Versagen sie auf ganzer Linie
da wurde doch vorhin der Kollege Arnold
zitiert er hätte mehr Munition gefordert
aber im Nachhinein immer gegen die
Erhöhung des Haushaltes zu sein oder
jetzt Herr leiser stellt sich hin und
sagt man müsste doch viel mehr Munition
ausgeben aber das Geld stellen sie doch
gar nicht zur Verfügung und wenn jetzt
auch noch festgestellt worden ist dass
die Grünen hier auf die Munition
verweisen die ja nie freuen denen der
Bundeswehr waren und die FDP Inhaber der
das Finanzressorts und als Vorsitz des
verteilungsausschusses diesem einen
zustimmen dann kann man sagen das ist
ein Verrat an den Interessen der
Bundeswehr das ist ein Wortbruch der
Bundesregierung das ist ein Versäumnis
in der Sicherheitspolitik Deutschland
das ist ein Offenbarungseid der neuen
Bundesregierung die Ampel steht
sicherheitspolitisch komplett auf
Störung
dabei bräuchten wir viel mehr Initiative
für Europa politische Initiativen wir
bräuchten ein gemeinsames
rüstungsexportprogramm wir brauchten
Beschaffungsvorgänge wir müssen viel
mehr deutlich machen dass wir zu unseren
Partner stehen auch zu Frankreich aber
auch dass wir Polen und Ungarn
motivieren mitzugehen die
Verteidigungspolitik das ist der Kit in
Europa hier müsste vielmehr erwartet
werden meine Damen und Herren auch hier
Fehlanzeige wir als Union haben immer
gesagt die europäische Säule muss
gestärkt werden komplementär zur Naht
und deswegen bleiben wir dabei wir haben
konstruktive Politik gemacht wir stehen
nach wie vor mit dem ganzen Herzen für
unsere Bundeswehr und für Frieden und
Freiheit in Deutschland und für Europa
und deswegen müssen wir diesen Haushalt
der Ampel ablehnen meine Damen und
Herren er wird der Lage leider nicht
gerecht
sagt Henning Otte und bekräftigt damit
noch mal die Linie der cdu/csu-fraktion
die ja doch ziemlich deutlich geworden
ist in dieser Aussprache über den
Einzelplan wird gleich abgestimmt in
zweiter Lesung zumindest aber eine
Rednerin haben wir noch Herr Maja Lisa
Völlers für die SPD
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe Frau
Ministerin liebe Frau werbeauftragte
meine Damen und Herren ich glaube ich
nehme uns jetzt mal wieder in die
Realität zurück weil was deutlich wurde
ist dass die Kollegen in der Union noch
durchaus irgendwie noch ihre
Vergangenheitsbewältigung hier betreiben
und einfach auch noch nicht ganz
verstanden haben dass auch sie einen
Beitrag dazu geleistet haben dass wir in
der Situation liegen in der wir gerade
sind und nun geht es darum dass in
Zukunft besser zu machen und damit die
Ampel gemeinsam dran arbeiten
vergangenes Wochenende liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen war ich mit anderen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier aus dem
Haus bei der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung der NATO kurz nato-pv in
Madrid zur jahreszeitung und natürlich
war auch dort das Thema des Krieges in
der Ukraine ein wichtiges Thema und wir
alle alle Parlamentarierinnen und
Parlamentarier der nato-pv wir sind uns
einig dass wir geschlossen hinter der
Ukraine stehen wir verurteilen den
Angriffskrieg Putins auf schärfste und
in einem anschließenden Gespräch mit der
ukrainischen Delegation ist eines sehr
sehr deutlich geworden wie wichtig auch
die Unterstützung Deutschlands für die
Ukraine in ihrem Verteidigungskampf
gegen Russland ist unsere Unterstützung
wird gebraucht sie sind sehr dankbar für
unsere Unterstützung auch wenn das bei
uns natürlich in den Beständen auch
Lücken reist danke noch mal an die
Ministerin an das Haus und an die vielen
Mitarbeitenden mitarbeiten die diese
Unterstützung an der Stelle erst möglich
machen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in Madrid
wurde auch angesprochen was ist das denn
mit der deutschen Zeitenwende auf sich
habe und welches die neue Rolle
Deutschlands sei und unser Bundeskanzler
hat ja bereits mehrfach betont wir sind
als Deutschland bereit auch
international mehr Verantwortung zu
übernehmen für die Sicherheit und für
den Frieden auf unserem Kontinent und da
gehört es eben auch ganz essentiell dazu
dass die Bundeswehr zum Grundpfeiler der
konventionellen Verteidigung hier in
Europa wieder werden muss und das geht
eben nur mit einer gut aufgestellten und
mit einer gut ausgerüsteten Bundeswehr
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen falls
sie irgendwie richtig zugehört haben
sollten der Kanzler hat heute noch mal
in der Debatte deutlich gemacht dass er
zu der Erreichung des zwei Prozent Ziels
steht das steht in dem Sondervermögen
die arbeiten daran und ich bin sehr sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir das gemeinsam
jetzt mit dem Haushalt aber insbesondere
auch mit den 100 Milliarden im
Sondervermögen erreichen werden über den
von uns gewählten Zeitraum Liebe Kolleg
und Kollegen
der Haushalt den wir hier debattieren
den 2023 hat eine Höhe von 50,1
Milliarden Euro und dort zusätzlich
müssen wir ja betrachten dass das was
wir planen aus dem Sondervermögen im
nächsten Jahr auszugeben dass sie noch
mal 8,4 Milliarden Euro im Mittelabfluss
und ich glaube das ist ein guter erster
Schritt in die richtige Richtung zu
unserem Ziel diese zwei Prozent auch
miteinander zu erreichen und wir haben
ja heute auch schon viel über dieses
Thema Munition gesprochen ich will das
gar nicht so sehr vertiefen weil
irgendwann ist auch alles gesagt ich
möchte noch mal auf einen Punkt
hinweisen der Kollege leise hat sie ja
ins Jahr 20.11 mitgenommen ich nehme sie
mal mit ins Jahr 20 15 also ein Jahr
nach der Annektion in der Krim da waren
es dann 256 Millionen Euro für Munition
im Haushalt dieses Jahr sind wir bei 1,1
Milliarden das heißt das ist eine
substanzielle Steigerung in diesem Feld
und ich weiß dass viele Kolleginnen und
Kollegen insbesondere der
Kollege Andreas Schwarz auch in der
groko sehr dafür gestritten hat diesen
titelansatz auch zu erhöhen also da
passt das dann mit der Erzählung
irgendwie nicht die böse
Sozialdemokratie habe das verhindert
was machen wir eigentlich noch in
unserem Haushalt ich glaube es ist ein
gutes Zeichen der Mittel für die
Materialerhaltung auszugeben und etwas
zu tun was auch schon einige Kollegen
erwähnt haben was ich auch persönlich
sehr wichtig finde die Länder noch mal
in die Verantwortung zu nehmen bei weil
bei Bauarbeiten bei Baustrukturen jetzt
endlich ein bisschen schneller zu werden
wir brauchen Kapazitäten für die
Unterkünfte für die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten das ist unheimlich wichtig da
bekommen wir alle immer wieder
Zuschriften und ich danke Ihnen
stellvertretend für alle Kameradinnen
und Kameraden für den Einsatz die sie
für unser Land für die Menschen in
unserem Land und darüber hinaus leisten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen zum
Abschluss dieser Debatte geht natürlich
der Dank noch mal an alle
ampelhaushälterinnen und Haushälter
sowie die Mitarbeitenden die sehr harten
Job hatten in den letzten Wochen und
viel gearbeitet haben und ich glaube das
ein Bereich den wir nur kurz gestreift
haben noch mal zu betonen ist nämlich
die Verdoppelung des handgeldes für die
Kommandeuren und Kommandeure ich glaube
das ist ein großer Schluck aus der Pulle
und in vielen Gesprächen mit
Kommandeuren hört man dass das durchaus
sinnvoll ist und dass sie sich da an der
Stelle auch gut aufgehoben und
unterstützt von uns fühlen von daher das
sollten wir weitermachen und gemeinsam
eben die Zukunft für die Bundeswehr
gestalten abschließend liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich glaube die zeitenwände
hat die allermeisten hier in diesem Haus
erreicht ich lade alle Demokratien und
Demokraten ein diese auch konstruktiv zu
gestalten sich nur und ewig in der
Opposition Rhetorik zu verlieren hilft
uns allen nicht weiter wird auch dem
Ansprüchen der Soldatinnen und Soldaten
und der zivilen beschäft möchten nicht
gerecht in dem Sinne bitte ich Sie auch
für unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten dem
Haushalt wie er vorliegt zuzustimmen und
das Sondervermögen wird seine Wirkung in
den kommenden Jahren entfalten
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]